foreign
all right good morning everybody's being
905. I'm gonna open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1643 FM
chair recognizes the prime sponsor of
Hillsborough County District 37 the
towns of Hudson and health
this bill will amend RSA 263.35 the
section that requires new residents to
transfer their out-of-state driver's
license to an in-state driver's license
to add an additional report to add
additional reporting requirements every
personal circumstances change within
those 60 days and minor penalties for
failing to do so
this bill is a follow-up to the letter
sent to end speaker Jasper on September
6 2017 by the Secretary of State and
commissioner safety which I have
provided to the committee
in this letter it was identified that
while
6540 individuals presented an
out-of-state driver's license while
using same-day registration to vote in
the 2016 general election roughly 10
months later
when the records were examined to
respond to speaker desperate's inquiry
which was well beyond the 60-day
requirement of RSA 26335
only 15.5 percent had since received a
New Hampshire driver's license
it is this dismal 84.5 unexplained
non-compliance rate that this bill seeks
the letter continues to theorize several
possible reasons why an individual may
not have transferred their license
including they moved back out of New
Hampshire before the 60 days were up
they ceased driving and gave up their
out-of-state driver's license before
these circumstances could certainly
occur and this bill creates a zero cost
form for an individual to report them to
the Department of Safety and face no
fines penalties or fees for doing so in
a timely manner
this will allow future reports on voter
registration Integrity to include more
accurate information
and dispel the theorizing myths
fear-mongering and willful blindness
that seems to permeate this discussion
this bill also modifies RSA 654 45
related to the information sharing from
the centralized voter registration
database operated by the Secretary of
State
the modification would require the
secretary to notify the department of
safety of apparent violations of 263.35
the database is already linked to the
Department of Safety for cross-checking
driver's license information with voter
records and flagging discrepancies
and this new requirement would
essentially require ongoing checks
similar to the one run for the 2017
letter for voter registration records
with out-of-state driver's license
information
this bill is also in party follow up to
2018's House Bill 1264 which clarified
the definitions of Thomas Island
residency in our lives effectively
making them the same thing
prior to this law one could in
circumstances circumstances be a
qualified voter without being subject to
RSA 26335
this is no longer the case
that law has twice been before the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
once due to a request for an advisory
opinion from the governor and Council
and a second time on questions certified
from the federal district court
and both times the court has addressed
the interaction between it and RSA 26335
and indicated that there were no
constitutional issues
quoting from the Court's opinion
simply put the state may legitimately
establish procedures by which persons
who may be tempted to insincerely claim
domicile for voting purposes are
discouraged from doing so by the
prospect that such a claim can result in
their occurring the full penalty of
obligations imposed on all other state
residents
the Court's decision continues from the
previous quote in a footnote indeed not
to correct this problem could be viewed
as fundamentally inconsistent with a
founding principle of our country
instead of no taxation without
representation current law effectively
allows some to obtain representation
without the payment of taxes or fees to
which other similarly situated persons
are subjected
I couldn't agree more and ask that you
please find this bill ought to pass and
make another step forward in correcting
this problem
thank you for your time consideration
I'd be happy to answering any questions
the community may have
thank you representative Amy questions
from the committee
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative
um
I guess I'm a little confused because
the
statute that you're amending here and
adding to find to
already is included in the uniform fine
schedule with a fine of 62 dollars for
the first offense and 124th of a second
so you're actually making the five
smaller
is that and I don't believe that is your
intention were you aware that there is
already a fine for this
um
violation
thank you for the question um you are
correctly did not realize that there was
in the universe applying scheduled and
that I was meeting the fine smaller but
I think one of the changes in this bill
would Define would be reoccurred and
there would be uh Department safety
wouldn't be able to send out recurring
notices until the situation was
corrected because while the current fine
I think views it as a one-term violation
it at least has its looked at in this
bill it's an ongoing violation until the
problem is corrected either by filing
the new forms stating why they haven't
transformed the driver's license or
accomplishing that transfer and so it's
an ongoing way that's looked evidence
bill is an ongoing violation in Turkey
instead of a one-time violation
let's follow it no follow-up thank you
so I guess I have
another concern with what you just said
that it's an ongoing fine
um there's nothing in this bill that
states
how the person would be notified of a
potential problem and it appears as this
bill is written that there would be
these ongoing fines that could
potentially go in perpetuity
um potentially having a very large
significant fine for what might be some
might call more of a minor offense
um
is there any way that you could address
that concern that the the person the
driver is
going to be surprised when they're not
being notified that uh this is
actually being a fine put against
something
uh thank you for the question
um I suppose I would completely
concerned a friendly Amendment so that
the recurring clients only begin once
they are notified of the initial time I
think it would still preserve the intent
of the bill but certainly the intent of
the bill is that it's in the situation
is considered an ongoing violation of
our laws until they correct
the discrepancy in one man or another
either by getting the license or by
filing one of the forms explaining why
they happened and why that's the correct
any further questions from the committee
um the written test my head was a
handout of the 2017 letter which I
believe you already have to have 20
sorry
letterhead
yes I was going to ask you the same
question because you did provide us a
lot of information this should be
CNN thank you very much
oh I'm sorry I didn't see it
representative
I just have one last question
um
I'm just curious how you envision uh
this happening in terms of enforcement I
mean are we going to be sending people
to
police to track down who might be on
this list I guess I just I don't
understand
um
is it going to be notifications VIA mail
what how do you envision this actually
being enforcement
thank you for the question
um
especially as relates to the individuals
they'll be flagged we'll be sharing the
centralized voter database we already
have their current driver's license
number
and I am assuming and I hope I'm correct
that we have a process to the Department
of Safety of sending violations out to
drivers where we have the driver's
sorry follow up and I always got that to
be through the mail okay sorry well I
just want to clarify if these are people
who don't have a New Hampshire
um
identification which is why they're put
on this list then how would the New
Hampshire DMV be able to
reach out to them
thanks for the question
um the
voting officials that operate for
checklist report their out-of-state
driver's license that they presented
when they did the same day registration
that has entered into the Secretary of
State's database that is exactly what
they use to generate the 2017 report is
they have both the state of issuance and
their driver's license information that
they presented during same-day
registration
which it was assumingly valid at the
time they did that same day registration
and I would expect they would use that
out of state driver's license
information
to and also they would have had to
provide on the same same day
registration form their in-state address
from which they're attending Thomas
offer voted and so between that we have
two ways of contact a member that
they're out of state driver's license
information which I assume we have
understood sharing agreements for how to
send violations to that State Drivers or
their in-state the address that they
claimed the vote with the voting down
the side so we have multiple ways of
contact from these people to follow up
all right thank you
representative Thompson
um
I'm a little unclear on how many people
are going to be involved in verifying
this it seems that some of this false
the Secretary of State's office as well
as motor vehicle and
if
if this sound is any amount of people at
all it's going to take some time to do
that and it seems like a financial note
of less than ten thousand dollars is
probably not accurate maybe the
Secretary of State can answer that
better for us but uh
there's a lot of hands handling this it
seems
did you did you have a question
representative I do I I I'm not sure how
we understand that the supervisors of
the checklist the Secretary of State's
office and the motor vehicle as supposed
to coordinate together to make this
thank you for the question
the advanced majority of the pieces in
this are already existing law existing
procedure and being done today the same
day voter registration information is
already entered into the central voter
registration database
and there's already a linkage between
that database and the registry of motor
vehicles database and they already do
electronic comparisons looking for
discrepancies and have a process to
follow up with voters and send them
notifications this would just be adding
an additional thing they're looking for
in the electronic check and I think
that's part of why the costs are so low
that there's already all the pieces in
in place to do this mostly
electronically and so this is not a hand
check that would you know involve a
significant amount of additional staff
to cross-reference those records
does that answer your question it does
thank you
before I ask for any other questions
from the committee I just wanted to say
we do have somebody from the Secretary
of State and the Department of Motor
Vehicles any other questions for
uh next up
looks like Catherine Heck from The New
Hampshire Municipal Association opposed
to the bill
good morning committee members my name
is Catherine Heck from The New Hampshire
Municipal Association and I am here to
oppose this bill based on the fact that
the revenues collected by and retained
by municipalities would be significantly
reduced well we cannot estimate exactly
did I call the wrong connections we're
on 1643. I'm sorry sir I thought I heard
my name I apologize I apologize thank
um okay I'll recognize uh Olivia zinc
from open democracy action opposed to
good morning members of the committee
for the record my name is Olivia Zink
and I'm the executive director at open
democracy action we're a nonpartisan
non-profit based here in Concord and we
really do need to modernize our election
system and Safeguard our elections to
ensure that only eligible American
citizens are casting their ballots but
I'm afraid House Bill
1642 is not the way to do it this is
before Transportation not election law I
do think you might want to vacate this
bill and send it to election law
the DMV
residency requirements are different
than the election law domicile
requirements and it's important to
consider that and the New Hampshire
Constitution when you're looking at the
domicile res
um
rules also getting your fishing license
or hunting license requires a different
residency requirement and I'm really
concerned that this bill targets college
students living in New Hampshire who
constitutionally have the right to vote
but may not receive a driver's license
as you know in 2006 2018 House Bill 1642
passed after that law passed I called
the DMV because I was very concerned by
RSA
6263 colon 5-e which is what requires
you to get a
what documents you need to get a
driver's license which is under that law
a lease but your dorm paperwork is not
the same as a lease and the DMV said
with your dorm documents you can't get a
New Hampshire driver's license so this
bill is adding a 10 a month penalty for
students to who don't get a driver's
license but then they can't get a
driver's license unless you amend a
different part of the statute to make
residency so I believe this will have a
chilling effect on those people who want
to vote in New Hampshire who
constitutionally are eligible to vote in
New Hampshire
also I have concerns about page 2 line
16 where the Secretary of State prepares
this list and I want to make sure that
the Secretary of State's office has the
needed Personnel in order to prepare
such a list with that I'm happy to take
any questions
thank you very much any questions from
tolerski thank you thank you for taking
my question
um
is it true that you can legally
vote in New Hampshire with an
out-of-state license
and this residency changing your license
within 60 days doesn't apply to you if
you are not a driver
if you don't drive in the state of New
Hampshire you do not fall under this
requirement to change your license
that is my understanding and also I
believe military veterans who are
serving
um and are stationed here in New
Hampshire also do not have to change
their license within 60 days as well
which is a U.S law around so you also
want to check in to military veterans
but but you're absolutely correct if
you're a voter who does not have a
driver's license this does not apply to
seeing none thank you very much
um
next up she recognizes looks like
Michael O'Brien two minutes from America
votes
uh in opposition to the bill seeking two
minutes
hi everybody I'm Michael O'Brien thank
you Mr chair members of the committee
I'm here on behalf of America votes I'm
with printing strategies uh speaking
today in opposition just a couple of
quick things that were sort of recovered
so I don't want to waste the committee's
time this morning but do want to
re-emphasize that you can vote without a
New Hampshire driver's license is a New
Hampshire and not fall into residency
laws and services committee knows if you
do not drive a vehicle
so the list that is being purported to
be sent from the Secretary of State's
office to the DMV will contain names of
people and essentially these folks would
start being into a fine schedule
um
that do not qualify or are not
breaking having any violations under New
Hampshire law secondly for the rolling
penalty I'm not aware and I've asked
some lawyers some criminal lawyers who
are not aware of Judges sometimes for
contempt of court will give a rolling
ten dollar fine you know ten dollars a
day if you don't do something but those
those folks who have been in front of
those judges have already had their day
in court and that's where this fine
comes into effect we are unaware of any
statute or violation that is rolling in
the state of New Hampshire or anywhere
without the person first being in front
of a judge or getting that fine assessed
to them after their day in court so for
someone to show up and I'll give an
example here it's entirely possible
under the statute that someone registers
to vote does not drive a car in New
Hampshire uses an out-of-state ID gets
put onto this list this ten dollar fine
starts to reoccur because that's the way
this bill is written four years later
they get a car they decide to start
driving a new after they go to New
Hampshire license they have a 500 fine
in front of them now this person is
going to court have to fight this 500
fine which they never should have
accrued in the first place
um it's a whole sort of logistical mess
uh within the system because the list
that is being pulled for what the
sponsor I believe is trying to do is
imperfect right because again there is
nothing illegal about voting without a
state ID in New Hampshire
um you know you'll prove your domicile
using different documentation right ID
just proves who you are doesn't
necessarily prove where you live we have
other documents that can do that within
the state and So within state law and so
there is nothing inherently wrong with a
person doing that but they will start to
accrue fines uh because of it I also
just want to point out in the case that
was mentioned around 1264.
in front of the Supreme Court the
Attorney General said in the Secretary
of State's office said that they would
not get involved in the enforcement of
of the law and so this would be a
dramatic shift from that from within the
court case and I'm happy to forward the
committee that documents that pertain to
that as well so I just want to emphasize
those points I think as written this
bill can cause a lot of problems not
just for students who I know were
mentioned but think of someone who moved
to New Hampshire who lives in a nursing
home and now are they put on the list
are we sending the unfortunate question
I'm not sure was answered it was a
little hard to hear but are we sending
police to nursing homes to find seniors
who use an out-of-state ID to vote but
again these seniors wouldn't qualify
under motor vehicle law because they're
maybe not driving here what is the next
step in this enforcement proceeding and
I think it can cause a lot of unforeseen
problems
that aren't necessarily fixes to
anything that we have and system right
now so happy to take any questions but
that's that's uh
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing that I have one I've heard that
uh for example college students aren't
required to get their license changed to
New Hampshire after well within the 60
days if they don't drive
correct
or anybody my question is how is it
determined or proven whether they're
driving or not
well I mean that's I mean that's a fair
question but I think that goes
you know we're not asking people nor I
think could we when they vote do you
drive a vehicle right but that's the
same it's not just students right so
again the senior in the nursing home who
goes and registers to vote who goes to a
nursing home in New Hampshire maybe move
from Mass to get closer to family or
whatever the case may be we're not
asking them either you know are you
driving a vehicle
um and so what what happens here is
you're going to have this list that is
factually inaccurate it's going to
contain people people are going to start
accruing fines because there is no
verification system within this list who
should not be doing that we're going to
end up with unnecessary court cases and
costs we'll also say from a burning
rights perspective under the sb3 case
the state just paid out five million
dollars to the law firm who sued the
state over the law and I'm sure if this
were to pass we'd be right back at it
again and I'm not sure the state wants
to start cutting checks and perpetuity
so I think we have to be very careful
when we make changes around election law
because these changes can oftentimes
lead to lawsuits and oftentimes the
state can spend a lot more money than is
necessary
thank you anything you can provide to
the committee would be appreciated it's
not always easy to hear and hear a lot
more information any other questions
from the committee
seeing on thank you very much thank you
uh next up chair recognizes Bob Perry
representing himself in opposition to
the bill seeking four minutes I hope you
good morning all
Mr chairman and members of the committee
I speak in opposition to 1643
challenging Donald Trump's protestations
of massive voter fraud in the 2020 New
Hampshire election
and relative the Wyndham audit which
produced no evidence of voter fraud
several quotes were captured by wmui's
John distaso
quoting the governor quote a discrepancy
of 300 votes out of over 800 000 cast
does not constitute massive voter fraud
in fact it is proof that New Hampshire's
voting process is the most reliable
safe and secure in the country and that
we will ensure every last vote is
accurately accounted for end quote
in a late afternoon briefing the
governor added quote if anything I think
the fact that we focused on 300 votes
goes to the Integrity of our system we
a system where we will do an audit even
if it is over a couple hundred votes end
quote he continued quote I don't know of
any other state that goes to such
extents but here our system
99.9 percent worked absolutely
wonderfully end quote
in another quote we are the model of
that other states want to be frankly end
quote
despite the governor's exuberance for
the Integrity of New Hampshire's
elections it has not stopped the
legislature from considering bills that
unnecessarily complicate the voting
process and infers voter bad faith
the language modifying current law is
dystopia
among some Provisions requires a person
who knowingly or unknowingly ceases to
be a resident of New Hampshire to notify
the department of motor vehicles within
15 days of face of fine of ten dollars
per month as punishment for not
reporting his her whereabouts
line 25b of the bill reflex current law
which describes the process of comparing
voter database information with
information and possession of the
Department of Safety
and the Social Security Administration
and the vital records Administration
this bill adds a requirement that when
an individual's information is derived
from an out-of-state driver's license
there must be a release of information
from the Secretary of State's office to
the Department of Safety
all of which adds to the potential for
leaking of private information confusion
potential for errors and expanded
investigations
John a fictitious name but a real person
told me he was living temporarily in
town B while waiting for final repairs
and sale of his home in town a
he was also waiting for his new home to
be built in town C
under these circumstances would you deny
him his freedom to vote because the
legislature argues over which town he
should consider his domicile
which town would you tell him he should
vote from town a b or c
would it be town a because that's where
he had established his domicile for
voting purposes even though he has moved
and looks forward to establishing voting
rights in town C
would you require he vote in town B
because that's where he has a physical
presence
if I were to add that this person moved
from out of state and was yet to
establish residency or domicile at
either towns a b or c
would you deny him his constitutional
right to vote anywhere in New Hampshire
you would if you you would if John threw
up his arms in frustration and concluded
voting is just too dangerous
this bill emerges a constitutional right
to vote with the privilege of driving an
automobile
we are a mobile Society
residency is a state of mind
domicile is a state of mind
both are as fluid as life itself
especially for young people
one legal definition cannot serve to
successfully contemplate all of life's
unknowns but we have historically
settled on one legal definition for
domicile found at 654-1
which for many years has successfully
served the interests of the state and
its voters
I urge itl
and I'll take no questions
thank you for reading your written
testimony to us
chair recognizes David Scanlon Secretary
of State
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State and I'm here not taking a position
on this bill but to provide you with
some information
excuse me I certainly understand where
the sponsors of this bill are coming
from and I'm a firm believer that to be
a voter in New Hampshire you should be
you have to be a resident and have your
the
the bill that you're dealing with today
and it kind of interacts with our
election laws
the part that that I would like to bring
to your attention is on page two
lines
14 through 18.
currently when a voter comes in to
register to vote they have to fill out a
voter registration form
and that form requires certain
information to be provided
some of the information is required by
the federal government specifically to
help America vote Act
which says that a voter should provide
their their driver's license number
or if they don't have that the last four
digits of their social security number
and if they don't have that a random
number voter number is assigned to that
individual for purposes of
the voter does not have to provide a
motor vehicle license and so most voters
do but there are quite a few voters who
have not provided that information
subsequent to registering to vote every
time after that that a voter goes into a
polling place to cast their vote
they have to present some form of
acceptable ID
that ID can be a driver's license it can
be an out-of-state driver's license and
it can be an expired license same would
be true with a passport or other
documentation that the local election
officials team appropriate
and if a voter has none of those things
they can meet that requirement by
signing an affidavit and having their
photograph taken
so they don't have to continue to
provide a driver's license to be able to
the requirement on page two says that
when an individual's record in the voter
database contains information derived
from an out-of-state driver's license
the Secretary of State shall notify the
department of safety of apparent
violations
of RSA 263 colon 35 and I I would
suggest that we as as the Department of
State are in no position to make a
judgment on whether there is an apparent
as a requirement of the help America
vote Act
the Secretary of State's office does
have to match our state voter database
up with a motor vehicle database on a
regular basis
and what that match does is it kicks out
voters names and addresses where there
are where it looks like it's the same
voter but there's a mismatch in the
information
and that is done so that that
information can be reconciled and it's
done primarily on the motor vehicle land
if as a matter of policy this committee
decides that it would be useful to
provide
out of state driver's license
information and
voter registration dates to the DMV so
that they could make a determination on
whether there were
a term here
apparent violations of the statute then
as the enforcement Authority for that
statute they would be able to look into
it
the Secretary of State's office
administers the elections we don't have
any enforcement authority over elections
that role is in the in the realm of the
Attorney General's office
um so I'll stop there Mr chairman and I
would be happy to answer any questions
if the committee has any
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative pilersky
thank you thank you very much for taking
my question this morning
sharing of public and sharing of the
voter list
um in 654
I think it's four or five it lays out
um
if this information is considered
private and how it can be shared into
what entities
can you does statute even allow you to
share that kind of information with
other departments
the Acoustics in here are not great so I
think I heard your question if I didn't
don't answer properly just let me know
um I the Secretary of State's office
maintains the Statewide centralized
voter database
and the information that the voter
provides on their voter registration
form is confidential except for that
information which is spelled out in the
statute appears on the public voter
checklist
so any citizen in the state has the
right to look at the voter checklist see
a voter's name
see that voter's mailing address and and
physical address
they can see their party affiliation
and I believe the voter identification
number
I know that the
Department of our vehicles has a
database of their own and they they
protect that information and the privacy
of those uh you know of those murder
Vehicle drivers in fact the databases of
both agencies are kept confidential
except to the extent that we can match
the databases up against each other
no no department is actually pulling
information from the other all that
spits out of the of the comparison or
those mismatches that need some form of
reconciliation so we're not taking
information from the motor vehicle
database and they're not taking
information
from the Statewide voter database
I'm not aware of any leaks that have
occurred through that process I know
that in terms of the elections database
we do everything that we can to maintain
the privacy of
the confidential information that voters
did that answer your question
can I I just want to clarify one thing
so there's nothing that would prevent
the Secretary of State's office from
sharing this list of Voters with
out-of-state driver's licenses with the
week by federal statute we can we can
match our databases
um
right to to to to share more than we're
sharing now would require legislation
which is in your domain and uh and
that's a policy decision that that I
any further questions from the committee
seeing that I just have one you did
indicate at the beginning that you may
you might see some merits of this and
some understanding has there been a
conversation with you on the prime
sponsor about maybe seeing something in
it that's amenable I'd be happy to have
a conversation with prime sponsor thank
you
thank you very much thank you uh the
last speaker on House Bill 1643
Kelly brednick from the Department of
good morning my name is Kelly bruniak
from the Department of Safety Division
of Motor Vehicles thank you for letting
me speak today I will be brief the
Division of Motor Vehicles does oppose
this bill
we feel at this point it's unclear in
many areas including how the lane
language shall be enforced by whom how
to calculate the fees there's several
questions that it brings up you know one
to bring up when someone becomes a
resident they do come in to get their
driver's license they provide residency
but they are not required to provide
when they became that Resident so we
would have to add different mechanisms
and how to track that how do they prove
when they became a resident so we feel
that this bill leaves a lot of questions
more than answers I can go into more
detail and answer any questions that you
may have
thank you very much any questions from
representative Gorski
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for taking my question when you have
an out-of-state
person comes in and wants to get a New
Hampshire driver's license what exactly
is that process what what documents must
they show
and prove that there are a New Hampshire
resident
thank you for your question so coming in
from out of state there are several
documents that they must prove they must
provide to us they need to prove who
they are typically that is in the form
of a birth certificate I'm only giving
you one the common the most common way
they do have to provide proof of their
social security is one of the other
documents that they have to provide they
do also have to provide if they have
driven in the past they would have to
provide their right to drive and that
would be that out of state driver's
license they also would provide
residency there are many things that we
would accept for residency one of them
rental or a lease agreement some of
those may have when it starts some of
them may not some people may live with a
family member so they would get a
notarized statement but again we do not
currently require them to tell us the
date in which they became a resident
just to prove that they are our website
currently does list all of our required
documents so we can go over those if
you'd like but also you can check those
thank you
further questions and I don't know what
keeps happening to our sound system but
seeing that thank you very much thank
you for your time anybody else wish to
speak to House Bill 1643
seeing that I'm going to close the
public hearing
give us a couple minutes to reset uh
foreign
like to open
House Bill 1570 FN relative to reducing
that's Mr chair
this is a
gonna take a minute to get used to the
for the record my name is Chief Ammon I
represent Hillsborough District 40 and
that's the towns of
New Boston Milford Mount Vernon and
Hollis
and I apologize the delay is kind of
messing with my uh
my ability to speak here
if you want to you can back up just a
little bit keep going back how about
there we can hear you yeah we'll have to
back away
I'm practically whispering right now
usually do that and hear me clearly
right okay Softly so with all that's
going on in the world right now this
might seem like a minor issue
the gist of the bill is to reduce
we know that uh
registration fees for automobiles
generate significant revenue for towns
um
we also know that
inflation is occurring
and the new car prices especially are up
over 10 around 10 percent uh year over
year so
the registration fees are based on the
list price of an automobile
so
if you look at the text of the bill it's
very simple bill it really just rolls
our millage rate forward one year
so there's five years
first year is the highest and we all
know this when we pay our registration
fee
it rolls It Forward from so it makes
year two year one year three year two
and so on
to alleviate some of the cost
of
vehicle registration fees
a new vehicle can be somewhere between
forty and fifty thousand dollars we're
getting to that point unless you're
going to buy a Honda Civic you know a
stripped down vehicle
and some people especially for work
trucks
an F-150
that's usable for say a landscaper
can be somewhere around 65 to 70
thousand dollars and so the registration
fee for the first year can be over one
thousand dollars
and I don't know about you but a
registration fee to me means that you
register your vehicle but
traditionally in New Hampshire this fee
has been used as more of a property tax
so there's a fee that goes to the state
that's fixed that's very small
with the military that goes to the town
is um
is much higher
so I looked up the history of this law
because that's always a good place to
start
the millage rate was established for
Motor Vehicles in 1919 so 100 years ago
and it was a four-year stepped rate the
first year was 17 Mills
it's a 17 per thousand
the second year was 12 Mills
third year was nine Mills
the uh I'm sorry
I think what 1712 953 so that's
zero to four years
then it's in 1921 it was raised to 24
Mills rate so it went it went way up
20 in 1925 it came down again and it
stayed that way 17 mils is the highest
until 1975.
in 19 between 1975 and 1980 is where we
get our current Village rate
so that's just some history that this
these numbers have fluctuated over the
years
now we're going to hear opposition and
it's understandable that this money even
though it's for automobiles and we know
automobiles use roads and bridges they
might even use the fire department
sometimes in the police department
sometimes
but this money goes into the general
fund of the town so the town can spend
it on whatever it wants
so we're going to hear that towns will
be affected their General Revenue will
be affected and that is that is
certainly the case if we change this
I think it's one of the
it's one of the genius things about that
instilling this in the first place and
it's difficult to touch it's difficult
to change
I had legislative research look up a
cross-section of towns to do every town
would have been too big of a task
to ask them to do so I had them do you
know the biggest cities to some small
towns
and it turns out the biggest cities they
their motor vehicle fees I'll give you
an example so Manchester gets about 14
million dollars per year in motor
vehicle fees and on public works that
would be roads and bridges and street
so Manchester would be the biggest
example they spend double what they take
in on public works if you just want to
consider it public works
but if you look at a small town like
Stratham
the population about 7 500.
they've taken almost two million dollars
in motor vehicle fees and they spend
about half a million dollars on public
works on roads and bridges so they're
they're taking a significant
four times they're taking four times
what they spend on roads and bridges
and that varies across the state
this fee is set in statute by the state
legislature so it does affect every town
but if you looked if you think about a
kitchen table issue when you're going to
pay on your birthday month happy
birthday you get to pay a thousand
dollars for your F-150 that you need for
your Landscaping Company
this bill would be designed to lessen
that burden a little bit and it would
require towns and cities to readjust
uh how they spend their money
one possible change to this bill this is
my final thought
is perhaps we could Target the money
spent on just things that apply to
automobiles within a town and then maybe
the money left over would go to a state
fund you know this would maybe alleviate
that issue where
you know it goes to a general fund it
can be spent on things that don't have
anything to do with automobiles if we
maybe could focus it just on
automotive automotive expenditures that
might be a the beginning of kind of
tying this to actual expenses
so those are my thoughts on this bill if
you have any questions I'll be happy to
answer
thank you for your testimony could you
get us those statistics that you were
talking about as far as how much money
that the cities and towns have taken in
get it to the committee somehow yeah
I'll go make a copy of this right now
it's not written testimony but it is a
spreadsheet okay hold on any questions
representative tolerski thank you thank
you for taking my question
representative Ammon
um one thing that I find is just lacking
on this bill is the fiscal note
understandably it's extremely difficult
to figure out how this is going to
affect towns I do not and the fact that
it's listed as indeterminable with just
a sixty six thousand dollar expense is
problematic when we look at the total
amount of money that's collected
Statewide on this I know my city
treasurer
um
expressed how devastating this could be
for my for my uh town where I live
can you
perhaps give us an idea of how a town is
going to make up the difference in order
to maintain the roads that these
thank you so you're speaking again to
this issue where this money goes into
the general fund
even though we're taxing automobiles
that could go to
to fund anything that the city decides
to do so to me we call this a
registration fee but it's really an
additional property tax we already have
some of the highest property taxes in
the state
we also have some of the highest
registration fees around the country so
um
to me it's the issue of
the principle of taxing someone's
automobile but not spending that money
on things the automobile uses right
and so I think that's kind of the
the structural flaw in the original Law
thank you
representative Airman
um
the thing that it puzzles me is that
how you talk about this registration
fees being in effect a tax a property
tax
and yet if you take away those funds
from all the cities and towns
they're probably the only mechanism they
have remaining to replace that revenue
is to increase property taxes
and I I think you're just giving you
know giving it back here and taking it
back over here
is that is that accurate
I don't disagree with that statement
it's more that the fact that the whole
thing is a shell game
you know you're you're taking money
you're you're saying you're you're
requiring people to pay a fee for a
registration fee for their automobile
but that is such a significant amount
that in a lot of these small towns it
goes to paying for lots of other things
that are not related to automobiles
so I have a follow-up if you may
it's thank you Mr chairman
um
the other part of this problem that I
have is that
you are
give and essentially you're giving a tax
break to people who are not property
owners
and forcing Property Owners to make up
the difference
how is that Equitable that's a great
question and this is something that most
people don't think about unless you're
homeless unless you're living on the
street you're living inside of an
apartment or a condo or house
that house that condo that apartment
might be owned by someone else that
someone else pays the property taxes and
passes those taxes on to the renter so
representative O'Hara thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um so I just wanted to make sure I'm
understanding what I think you're trying
to do with this bill
all right it sounds like you'd be
amendable to making towns have to have
separate funds if they get this money
and work on streets and stuff like that
right so they can specify it's for
automobile is that kind of your
Direction with this
that's one potential Direction
um
so the current mill rate is 18 down to
three dollars yeah so maybe 15 is too is
too low maybe we can go more
traditionally with 17 12 9.
five and three that that's the way it
was for majority of the last hundred
years
but that that would be another potential
follow up thank you so it and last
question would be if we do lower the
rate and we ask the town to increase
death increase in property tax clearly
that money will go in the general fund
and the people of the town will then see
actually how much the town is costing
them rather than trying to mix the
property tax and registration fee
together see how much it cost them
that would certainly be a way to go I
don't know how popular it would be with
the Town Administrator but at least the
money that you pay for your car goes to
things that your car uses includes
any other questions for the
representative
thank you
next up
Catherine
heck
New Hampshire Municipal Association I
think
good morning committee members and I
apologize for being a little early on my
testimony before yesterday was a holiday
so I guess today is my Monday so my name
is Catherine heck I am with the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and I am
the government Finance advisor we are
speaking in opposition to House Bill
1570 as vehicle registrations are the
second largest source of Municipal
Revenue in our communities monthly
registrations provide consistent revenue
streams assist with cash flow and
reduces the amount of money that has to
be raised in local property tax a
reduction in motor vehicle fees equates
to raising the property tax to make up
for this reduction
this legislation reduces the amount of
Revenue retained and collected as
unrestricted by the municipalities the
town permit fee as you've heard in
testimony is based on the model year the
factory list price and the expiration
date of the registration I will note
that it is not possible for us to
calculate the predict precise reduction
by registration information because that
is not broken down and the data we can
collect by model year by town
I did submit a fiscal note when the LSR
came out the full note was not included
on the bill so I will testify with that
information now
using the revenue collected the actual
Revenue collected in 2019 and now I do
have the information for 20 which was
not available last November
I calculated the degrees and fees by
percentage using the average of the six
permitting fees
rather than using the simple average
calculation mathematically I use the
geometric mean because that uses a
central tendency and tosses out the high
and low outliers because again we can't
calculate by model year
296.7 million dollars was collected in
Municipal motor vehicle registration
fees the data source is the New
Hampshire Public Finance Consortium you
can get this data
it's accessible to anyone at
www.nhpfc.org
so when using that geometric mean the
reduction is about 90 million dollars a
year based on 2020 information
in 2019 approximately 289
000 was collected and we estimate again
using that mathematical calculation
80.4 million dollar reduction
so just to put this in some perspective
the legislature last session generously
increased your meals and rooms to
municipalities at the 30 percent level
and this would essentially zero out that
hundred thousand dollar meals and rooms
that we had seen so therefore having no
additional effect on reducing taxation
because we would have to be making up
for that so
I can take any questions that you might
have
any questions for this Witness
representative O'Hara
thank you Mr chairman I just want to see
if we could get the data that she just
when we're done with you ma'am would you
do you have a copy of your testimony
that she could have I I do not have a
copy but I can certainly email it to you
right after the presentation absolutely
that's about my pay grade but she knows
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um you mentioned that if this gets
reduced that we automatically is going
to make an increase in property taxes
are there other other areas
that can be impacted versus property
taxes and what I mean by that is have we
looked at any other areas to make this
or even look at maybe
you know making some looking in other
areas
so that's a great question and
unfortunately the revenue side when we
set the tax rate offsets you know we
reduce the tax the tax amount of
appropriated expenditures that the town
approves we subtract the revenues and
that's how we get to the tax rate so
unfortunately any reduction in revenues
you had asked previously if I may about
um money is being dedicated to Road in
Bridge work this RSA that allows for the
collection of Motor Vehicle fees already
has a provision for the cities and towns
to raise an additional optional
transportation fee tax for those who are
already
exceeding on the dollar amount that they
collect in motor vehicle fees for their
Road and Bridge work
so there is an optional tax that 35
communities currently have enacted since
1996 to additionally offset that so
they're
to look at a bigger picture to your
point I'm not seeing an easy solution on
where we could adjust so it doesn't hit
the local property tax rate does that
answer your question sir
thank you for taking my question are you
aware of any studies that have been done
that
a tribute by percent or other method to
what
a property tax might be for rental
properties versus the rent that they
charge
I'm sorry sir I'm having trouble hearing
you could you repeat the question I do
apologize no I'll get closer is that
better yes sir sorry are you aware of
any studies
that show the connections or the
attribution to rents that are charged
and and how much that property tax May
factor into that
I I do believe there are studies from
the fiscal policy Institute that discuss
how tenants are charged based on
taxation I could try to find them for
you and send them along sir that'd be
go ahead I'm just curious
um when you asked for a testimony on on
the um the data that she had may I
requested that go to the whole committee
I just don't know if she was going to
send it directly to uh the clerk or
that's a good question may I ask that it
be sent to the whole committee sure for
that for that fiscal note information
would you send it to the whole committee
please yes sir thank you thank you
any other questions
our final
Witnesses Joan Joanne dargy or darje New
Hampshire City and town clerks
Association
how'd I do
um so I won't repeat the municipal
Association said a lot of things that I
was going to say so I'm not going to
repeat that so I'm just going to get
down to the basics
um Milford alone
lose six hundred thousand dollars the
first year if this bill passes
if it passes in the middle of a year
we've already calculated our budgets I
don't know where we're going to capture
this These funds that are missing the
city and took Clerk's Association did a
calculation on Salem New Hampshire they
um what I want to mention is what we're
forgetting is after the vehicle is five
years old it goes down to lowest mill
rate so you're getting your lower
straight after five years if like me
because I register cars every day when I
buy a new car I buy a new three or four
or five year old car I don't buy a new
new car so
um the other thing is is that businesses
aren't rentals
businesses build the cost of registering
these vehicles into the cost of doing
business
if we lose their vehicle registration
rates on the businesses
that all of that is just going to
property tax I mean and it's not it's
not hitting rentals I mean a lot of
businesses have just a little one
building and they've they're renting
cars or they're it's a parking lot but
they store their vehicles in so you're
not gaining anything from them paying
more property tax
um
and you know and you have to keep in
mind you know when he mentioned that it
not all that money is being spent on
roads
that you've got it's DPW it's fire and
its police those are all all should be
combined together when the when the
money in our everything that we're
collecting in Milford is going to those
three departments
um other states what I see when we
register Vehicles some people come in
and they they get that you know first
bill obviously everybody's buying trucks
right now trucks are the most expensive
thing vehicle to to register but if you
were in Vermont Maine Massachusetts
you'd be paying sales tax more than what
our registration cost is I mean you have
to look at why are people always trying
to figure out a New Hampshire address so
they can register their vehicles because
it's where the cheapest place in the
area to register vehicles
um
and I I think that's
basically I mean we have two places to
collect revenues in the town and it's
motor vehicles and property tax and this
is just a shift to property tax
any questions for those witness but keep
in mind that we are almost 15 minutes
seeing none thank you very much thank
you could you uh email your testimony to
the committee that would be great thank
you
any other Witnesses who wish to testify
in House Bill 15
FN
foreign
good morning being 10 20. I'm going to
open up the public hearing on House Bill
uh chair recognizes the prime sponsor
thank you Mr whoa okay then
thank you for hearing me today I'm
representative Stephen Smith Sullivan
County District 11 Acworth Charlestown
Goshen langder Leominster in Washington
let me open with an apology in my 12
years serving in the legislature it was
the first time I've ever set foot in
this historic chamber without a tie I
had to switch cars unexpectedly there it
is ironic that we're talking about
apparel today and no it's not a stunt I
would have come here with no sleeves and
jeans that worked for a living if it was
a stunt
this is a simple bill it's a bill that
says you can't be stopped you team to
search because of what you chose to wear
today
that's all it does there should have
zero impact on law enforcement however
if it does then that's certainly proof
that the bill was needed
if you're wearing motorcycle
paraphernalia don't giggle
you can't be stopped just because you're
wearing that I got asked a question
yesterday that kind of wound me up so
does this mean we can't pull over
anybody wearing a Hell's Angels jacket
that's silly what they can't be pulled
over for is wearing the jacket however
if it's part of a description and a
crime that just happened of course
here's a scenario
a business gets robbed the description
of the purp goes out it's a five foot
tall white male weighing 135 pounds with
blue hair wearing a Harry Potter t-shirt
now if within a mile of the business you
find this Harry Potter wearing
blue-haired Vespa riding perp
he matches the description yes you can
pull him over he's being stopped to
Tandem question because he matches the
description not because he was wearing
the Harry Potter t-shirt now I ask you
to consider that scenario and substitute
a rolling thunder jacket a red Electra
Glide
shouldn't laws apply to everybody
equally it shouldn't matter what our
wardrobe Choice was today
my name's at the top but this is the
speaker's bill
he cares deeply about this and is
actually himself experienced some
discrimination I don't know if you guys
know what he looks like when he's not
here but it might surprise you
look around the room you're going to see
people wearing that dangerous motorcycle
paraphernalia but let me tell you what
you do see
UC New Hampshire you see professionals
you see people working regular jobs you
see veterans retirees you see people
engaged in worthy causes I saw a bunch
of people walk in sit in front of me
wearing what's said Bikers Against Child
Abuse
they do all of these things because
they're just regular people like you and
they shouldn't be discriminated against
both of our sides have some common
themes on one side I hear Freedom
Liberty
to be free from government interference
when I'm going about my life I hear that
we should have a welcoming inclusive
environment where everybody has the same
Equity opportunities and is not
persecuted because of what they look
like what I'm asking the committee today
is to affirm all that tell these people
that we mean it and pass this Bill thank
you Mr chair
thank you representative any questions
representative tolerski
thank you for taking my question
representative Smith
um I love the idea of this and I'm
wondering why we have to limit it to
motorcycle riders are there other
classes that we could protect
I'm sorry my hearing a shot could you do
that again sorry
[Music]
I'll try to be slow and loud
I was going to say I love the idea of
the Bill I'm wondering why we
have to restrict it to Simply Riders of
motorcycles are there any other classes
that we could protect from this kind of
action by profiling them
but what I mean profiling in general we
already have profiling laws
um that there are certainly state and
federal laws and I mean really shouldn't
it just be that you can't be treated
differently because of what you look
like and this isn't currently on the
books so we just like to put it there
thank you
further questions from the committee
CNN thank you very much thank you
next up and share recognizes looks like
Vince Sylvia in support of the bill
representing himself
okay
welcome
good morning uh my name is Sylvia I'm
from Salem New Hampshire uh I have one
question
what do I do for a living
well I'll tell you what I do for a
living I'm the director of I.T for a
software company I've worked for NASA
I've worked for MIT the Library of
Congress the U.S Senate and I've taught
classes for IBM
I've been stopped just because I was
wearing leather
that was the only reason why I was
stopped there was no other probable
cause I've been out riding with my my
buddies doing charity runs and we've
been stopped just because we were
wearing leather
and that is why I'm in support of this
bill
thank you
she recognizes Bill Murphy representing
welcome
uh thank you chairman committee members
my name is Bill Murphy I live in
Manchester New Hampshire
um just to give a little background I
moved from Massachusetts uh back in 1986
um I had ridden motorcycles up to that
point my first 10 years living in New
Hampshire I was raising two boys so I
wasn't riding at the time
about 10 years in I bought a motorcycle
again and started riding and uh it
seemed at that point I was looked at
differently because of being on a
motorcycle wearing leather and so on
um
so there's been cases of of myself being
pulled over but I'd like to cite two
examples that seem to be the most
egregious to me just to put this in
context because curiously enough this
context applies to both examples
I'm a long time boxing trainer
uh for over 30 years I've been training
boxes in the last 22 years I was a
volunteer trainer at National Police
Athletic League boxing gym
um my wife and I recently a few years
ago moved to Manchester we bought a
condominium so I looked for a gym
locally and I knew of the Manchester
Police Athletic League gym
so I went there and spoke to the Head
trainer who welcomed me in said I'd be a
perfect fit we both knew each other from
boxing circles
um they have a strict application
process so he said you'd have to fill
out an application which I did
and submitted that
only to then and I have copies of the
return letter from the executive
director of the Manchester Powell
um and I'll just read the reply from him
he's a solo bill I had the opportunity
to speak with both the past and
president mpal who wouldn't his message
to Powell
uh the Manchester Police Athletic
Manchester Police Department officers
assigned to the mpal full-time
while we certainly appreciate your
training experience and willingness to
provide character references membership
and a motorcycle club that could be
perceived as supportive of other clubs
with known or assumed connections to
criminal activity remains a concern that
prevents us from welcoming you as a
trainer at mpal
our volunteers activities in and out of
the gym reflect on both mpal and the MPD
and even the perception of affiliation
with an organization that that do not
share our values must be considered in
our selection office process and then he
he wished me luck in finding a gym uh to
again volunteer at
so that's just a case of being a
motorcyclist and obviously being a
member of a motorcycle club where that
alone was enough regardless of my
experience and the value that I could
add
uh working with kids in in an
underprivileged area
was enough to decline my application
uh the other example is in 2019 I was
leaving natural PAL boxing gym I was on
my motorcycle I was wearing this vest
and as I turned off of Ash Street onto
West Hollis Street I was pulled over
it turns out it was the natural gang
task force
so the officer upfront acknowledged that
he had no reason to pull me over he said
I just want to ask you some questions
so I respectfully respectfully asked if
I could then leave given that there was
no reason to pull me over it and he
insisted that I say
so we went on to ask a few questions and
I I don't need to go and I don't think I
need to characterize his questions but
um there were some insinuations about my
membership in a motorcycle club
uh when I continued to respectfully
decline to answer he then finally said
okay you can you can be on your way
so that stop took about probably about
15-20 minutes or so
and again it was a national gang task
force who acknowledged up front we had
no reason to pull you over we just
wanted to ask questions
um and then let me go
uh so those are the two most egregious
examples I can come up with there are
others but I have copies of the letter
uh the email response from mpal
Manchester Police Department League I
can hand those out to you folks
um so if you have any questions
thank you very much and certainly please
hand those forward any questions from
changing my plans here I know the
speaker is busy I actually have
recognizes representative Packard
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
um
I just wanted to come up and say oh
important I believe this bill is
but before I go any further I want to
say this is not a reflection on law
enforcement in any shape a manner
I have the greatest respect for law
enforcement and all of you have seen a
letter I just put out supporting law
enforcement
but this is a problem not as major in
New Hampshire as it is in some of the
states but it's it's a problem that I
have personally been a victim of
and let me quickly tell you my story
uh it was three or four of us riding out
in Route One a uh on the Beach Road in
uh Rye
it's not to get something to eat we're
heading back to 101 to head home
I got pulled over
and I was pulled over by a riot police
officer and I said
why did you pull me over they said you
passed a car in a double yellow line
well I think any of you that have been
on that road in the summertime know that
that's an impossibility
and I in fact did not pass a current
and I when I said I did not win any such
thing he said well you were writing on a
double yellow line
I said well
I might have touched it a few times but
I was not riding on a double yellow line
20 minutes later I was let go
why he decided to profile me and not the
other members other people I was with I
don't know
and it's irrelevant so it does happen
and I just wanted to relay that story to
you that we do have a small problem in
New Hampshire and this bill just fixes
that problem and I will hope that you
would all support it
um so that we can all make sure that
just because we're riding a motorcycle
we unprofiled
regardless of what kind of attire we
happen to be wearing which most of the
time is jeans and
not in the summer but in fall or spring
a leather jacket so please give that to
careful consideration and hopefully we
can get any unanimous audit pass on a
committee thank you Mr chairman
thank you I will take questions if
anybody has some any questions from the
committee
uh last person I have signed up to speak
uh Tracy borvas representing the New
Hampshire motorcyclist rates
organization in support of the bill
thank you chairman Walsh you have to
laugh because I said y'all
no it was the morning good afternoon
chairman Walsh committee members thank
you for the opportunity to speak
I'm Tracy borvage I'm the president of
New Hampshire motorcycle rides
organization also known as nhmro
I'm a biker
I'm also an entrepreneur I am several
companies
I also sit on a board of veterans count
which raises money for veterans I'm a
I'd like you to look at the jacket or
the vest not back the best that I wear
I ride I want you to see the back of my
breast
[Music]
I like black I like Gothic weird things
it's a part of who I am part of my taste
do I talk too loud
bikers are routinely discriminated upon
because of what we wear
are long beards
the leather jackets leather vests the
clothes that we wear
currently there are four states
that have motorcycle legislating
anti-profiling motorcycle legislation
they are Idaho Louisiana Washington and
Maryland
I'd like to point out a couple of points
that I think are important back in 2011
New Hampshire enacted HB 148 which
prohibited the acceptance of federal
funding from motorcycle only roadside
checkpoints here on the granite state
it's important
I'd like to quote what representative
John tholl wrote in his February 11th
2011 house Transportation committee
report
this bill states that no entity in the
state of New Hampshire accepts Federal
funding solely for the purpose of
setting up motorcycle only roadside
checkpoints
this would be a clear example of
discrimination against one group of
citizens just because of what type of
vehicle they use for means of
transportation
so they recognize that we were being
singled out because we ride motorcycles
in 2018 New Hampshire took the step one
step further
by enacting SB 516 which simply
prohibits any law enforcement officer or
agency from establishing or conducting
motorcycle only checkpoints
and I'd like quoting from representative
Peter torosian's house Transportation
committee report of April 4th 2018.
this bill is to ensure that motorcycles
and their Riders are not singled out
unfairly from other motorists and forced
into roadside checkpoints for
inspections when law enforcement does
not otherwise have probable cause for a
traffic stop
as you can see this legislative body
heard the concerns of New Hampshire
motorcyclists both in 2011 and 2018.
and they agreed
that this action would single us out
simply because
of what we rode
motorcycles
in 2018 the U.S Senate resolution 154 a
resolution promoting awareness of
motorcycle profiling and encouraging
collaboration and communication with the
motorcycle community and law enforcement
officials to prevent the instances of
profiling past humanist consent
and then of course we had the pandemic
So currently in the U.S Congress session
the house resolution 366 promoting
awareness of motorcycle profiling
encouraging again collaboration
communication with the motorcycle
community and law enforcement officials
to prevent instances of profiling has 78
co-sponsors including our
Representatives Chris Pappas which I
reached out to and Amy Custer so both of
them have signed on
we have a long history here in New
Hampshire
of motorcycling we have the oldest
motorcycle rally in the country in
Laconia people come from all over the
world to ride here in our state with
beautiful roads
nhmro along with the New Hampshire of
Highway Safety started a motorcycle task
force
we've brought in the state police
we brought in the New Hampshire writer
education program
the New Hampshire Automobile Dealers
Association
AAA of New England I heart media and the
Liquor Commission to work on New
Hampshire and hmrs ride smart program
which deals with these types of issues
we feel like this is a great start
unfortunately
we as a community are still being
discriminated against so be types the
types of clothes we wear the way that we
look
people fear what they do not like or
what they do not understand
and I believe that motorcyclists are
very misunderstood
I can tell you that when several of us
walked in here today
we were not looked at very well
that's not acceptable
so I implore you please
pass HP 1000
and put New Hampshire in the Forefront
again
with important legislation
thank you and yes I will answer any
questions
thank you very much any questions from
they're letting you off the hook thank
you very much thank you
that is the last person I have signed up
to speak in terms of pink card
is there anybody else
here that wishes to speak to house bill
1000.
certainly so just please uh recognize
who you are and when you're done I do
need you to fill out a pink card for me
I'm sorry
um when the state decides to do air
conditioning in all these rooms they
might update the speakers
these sock but anyways sorry
um
my name is Tom Levesque I'm from dairy
and I also have a camp up in a North
Country
I'm here to support the bill in all my
road riding friends I'm a Trail Rider
I've had road bikes but I'd like to
introduce the idea that trail bikes are
also motorcycles even though the state
as far as trails are concerned sees them
as ohrvs two summers ago I was riding
with eight friends who had ATVs or utvs
the bigger units and two of us had
motorcycles as we approached the sheriff
the sheriff pulled out two of the
motorcycles me and another fellow and
let the ATVs pass once stopped he asked
for oh HIV registration a license and or
certificate showing training went on to
check our exhaust
et cetera Etc he found nothing wrong why
did he pull us over we were motorcycles
we were profiled thank you
thank you sir uh I'm assuming it wants
no questions uh I do have another pink
I'm sorry I was just putting the pink
cards over here for people to fill it
did you I do have a card from you did
I'll make it free
from there not really in my repertoire
but I'll try
uh thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee I'm here to support this
bill today because I too ride
I don't look like it I don't look like
everybody else in this room but I write
I enjoy it
I'd ride with a helmet I ride without a
helmet I've been pulled over just
because I ride
so I ask that this be considered and we
support this bill OTP thank you
thank you sir
that is my last pink card one last call
anybody else wish to speak to house bill
1000.
I will close a public hearing on this
bill
we do we do have some time before our
next hearing if you could give me a
couple of minutes to speak with my
colleagues there is a chance we might be
able to exec this now give me a few
minutes
foreign
okay ladies and gentlemen thank you for
your patience
um at this time I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 1000.
chair recognizes representative Hill for
a motion
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman at
this time I'd like to
move on to pass on House Bill 1000
great motion is ought to pass is there a
second second
representative gagne first
representative Hill do you wish to speak
the emotion briefly Mr chairman uh Mr
chairman
um I think all of us in the room uh
believe that discrimination is bad in
any way shape or form
it should never come down to the clothes
we wear
or are grooming
or
any reason other than perhaps how we're
operating a motor vehicle for whether we
are pulled over or stopped or questioned
so for those reasons I would move up to
foreign
representative Sykes
thank you chairman Walsh um I would like
to agree with the representative that
any form of discrimination is a bad
thing and we
um and I can support this bill I look
forward to this the opportunity that
this presents the legislature to further
Define other protected classes that may
are not getting as much recognition for
the problem as they deserve and so I see
this as a good precedent to set and we
can continue to look forward to
thank you anybody else from the
committee
representative O'Hara thank you Mr
chairman I just want to Echo the speaker
real quick that this isn't um a shot at
the police or anything like that it's we
just want to help our citizens
thank you anybody else from the
committee
I will just add that the legislature has
seen fit in the past to deal with this
issue in terms of motorcycles both with
Federal funding and with the state law
just prohibiting the Discrimination that
motorcycle only checkpoints in the past
which demonstrates to me there is an
issue here so I will be supporting this
as another layer of protection I
encourage everybody on the committee to
vote yes
thank you and at this time with nobody
else the chair will recognize the clerk
uh Vice chairman Cagney
yes
clerk votes yes representative Hale yes
representative Thompson yes
representative Gorski
yes representative O'Hara yes
representative Sykes
okay
representative Rambo
yes representative rich
yes representative tolorski
yes representative Fox yes
representative Stevens
yeah representative Vego yes and
chairman Walsh
yes
14-0
so the committee recommendation of ought
to pass is adopted 14-0 I would move
consent consent is moved by
representative gagne or is the second
for consent
representative seconded by
representative Hill with no objection
consent it is uh that will conclude the
for the committee we do have an
additional hour
you want to chat or do you want to just
have a long lunch before our Long
Afternoon
foreign
okay guys we're gonna take a break we'll
more appreciate that thank you so I can
foreign
I'm going to open up the public hearing
actually before I do open up the public
hearing just a couple things I want to
want to mention uh for anybody that's
ever been to one of these hearings
before uh in the anti-room we call it
out back if you'd like to sign in either
way on the bill for or against look for
a blue sheet with 1424 on it if you do
wish to speak there are pink cards you
need to fill those out and pass those
forward we do already have quite a
collection
um
I guess that's all I need to say at this
point I'll open up the public hearing on
1424. I'm going to introduce the prime
sponsor recognize the prime sponsor our
representative bordes and lastly because
of the volume of cards I am going to
limit the testimony to three minutes a
piece
I have some copies of my testimony and
some facts
um if you guys want copies or you want
Mr chairman and members of the House
Transportation committee I thank you for
listening to House Bill 1424 relative to
the speed limit on Lake Winnipesaukee
this issue was brought to me by many of
my constituents within the wheels Beach
Community
um
let's start with a brief history of Lake
Winnipesaukee which is our largest
inland body of water in New Hampshire
and how the speed limit got enacted in
2005 House Bill 162 was introduced and
Pierce the house R and D committee that
year from from 11 to 10 roll call vote
and Pierce the House vote was 185 to 153
the Senate killed the bill by a 15-8
roll call vote in 2008. in 2007 House
Bill 847 was introduced The Spill
started as a speed limit on all lakes
within New Hampshire
as it worked its way through the house
process it was amended to be a speed
limit on Lake Winnipesaukee only now I
must clarify Lake Winnipesaukee is the
only inland body of water in the entire
State of New Hampshire that has an RSA
dedicated to it
um that bill passed into law and also
had a prospective repeal for 2011. a
current Speaker of the House Sherman
Packard for the minority and
transportation stated
is this just another law that will
punish all responsible Boat Owners
because of the irresponsible actions of
a very small percentage of Boat Owners
do we really believe that by passing
this law that this small percentage of
inconsiderate and irresponsible people
will change their habits
Allure is not going to make anybody
change their habits
in 2010 houseboat 464 was introduced to
repeal the repeal it Pierce and was
signed into law rep John a hickle for
the minority of Transportation while the
bill is well intended the minority
believes that a two-year study will
determine if speed causes an unsafe
condition while the department of safety
does not take a position on whether it
does what does not and there is no
statistics presented to the committee by
either the bill sponsor or director of
safety the two-year study has only been
allowed to have input on one year of
questionable data and piercing this bill
is premature Based on data presented to
the committee so they set up for a
two-year study
and they only allow one year of it and
stop the study
in 2011 there was an effort to focus on
the speed limit on the broads only now
the broads is basically the size of 14
Manchester airports
it's a big wide open body of water
it's not overpopulated
um it's just a great place for people to
be able to open their throttles up and
move around
um
the minority transportation
the minorities in support of this bill
because there is no evidence that
supports the notion that speed alone
affects safety
now this is factual speed alone does not
affect safety
alcohol is one of the major reasons for
accidents within all bodies of water
we also haven't issue New Hampshire has
a 150 foot rule which means if I'm
operating my vessel I have to be 150
feet away from the shoreline other boats
other personal watercraft where the only
state in the country I know that has a
150 foot rule on a safe passage rule
um
so in regards to the um the broads only
Bill the minority believes that the
bipartisan Senate compromise is a fair
one the increase in speed would only
affect the vast area known as the broads
which is approximately 30 square miles
long or about the size of 14 Manchester
airports this basically boils down to a
liberty issue as long as a voter follows
Coast Guard rule six we believe that
there should be
they should be able to travel at a speed
they believe is safe and courteous
um so let's talk about Coast Guard rule
six which states every vessel shall have
at all times proceed at a safe speed
that she can take proper and effective
action
to avoid collision and be stopped within
a distance appropriate to the prevailing
circumstances and conditions in
determining the safe speed the following
factors shall be among those taken into
account
and this is four vessels
the state of visibility
the traffic density including
concentrations of fishing vessels and
other vessels so we have 150 foot rule
so voters are supposed to be 150 feet
away from kayaks canoes and other motor
vessels
but the Coast Guard has a little
different view uh view on this the
maneuverability of the vessel and
special reference to stopping distance
and turning ability in the prevailing
conditions at night the presence of
background light such as form
Shore lights or from back scatter or all
nights the state of wind sea condition
and current and proximity of
navigational attitudes the drift and
relations of our valuable death of water
now remember in New Hampshire we have a
150 foot rule which many other states do
not have the 150-foot rule in New
Hampshire States you cannot operate a
vessel at greater than Headway speed so
Headway speed is the fastest speed you
can go or not really the fastest but a
speed you can go to maintain
drivability or maneuverability of the
vessel so I don't know if any of you
guys have voted before but if you're
going through a no wake zone you're
typically traveling at three to six
miles an hour to maintain movability of
that vessel
um also in New Hampshire we have to be
150 feet away from swimmers other
vessels rafts or floats permitted
swimming areas dachshund Mooring fields
and the shoreline
the 150 foot rule makes New Hampshire
one of the safest boating states in the
entire New England area
there have been many false claims by
opponents of this bill that fast boats
create large waves this is factually and
scientifically wrong
I provide you with a study proving the
statement wrong but to sum it up at
higher speeds power boats level out
leaving a far less wake than transition
speed
smaller planing boats will barely even
kiss the water when they are going fast
displacing a very very little water so
if you're driving your boat at let's
just say 15 to 20 miles an hour you're
going to kick a huge wake back and you
can see that as you throttle up and get
on plane the week is going to dissipate
and become smaller
let's talk about equal access to the
lake
first off of 135 Fish and Game boat
ramps in the state 66 Alcoa top only so
a car top only ramp means only available
to kayakers canoes paddle boards I
cannot take my boat and put it on top of
a car and use it now these vessels or
these
paddle boards and canoes do not pay
registration fees they do not pay to
access our body of water every single
boat owner has to pay a registration fee
and additional fees in order to access
our Lakes so to me that is not equal
access
opponents of his bill keep saying that
high speed on a motor vessel is a safety
issue this has been proven wrong time
and time and time again
speed has never been a safety issue on
Lake Winnipesaukee I provided you with
data from New Hampshire Marine Patrol
showing there has only been one speed
related accident in the past 10 years we
don't know if alcohol was a contributor
to that accident
but one accident a speed greater than 65
miles an hour in 10 years
shows me that speed is not an issue and
it was not an issue prior to this law
being enacted
safety was never the real reason for the
speed limit to begin with
it was a group of homeowners that did
not light speed boats
they didn't like the noise they didn't
like their visual times have changed the
majority of speed boats nowadays run
outboard engines
their four-stroke engines you could
barely hear them go by we also in the
state of New Hampshire have a noise
ordinance on motor vessels that's Marine
Patrol strictly enforces
I've seen them out there all the time
with their decibel meter reading reading
the decibel levels of vessels so you
cannot vote
with a Extremely Loud vessel on our
water
includes in Winnipesaukee is the only
Lake in in New Hampshire with an RSA
pertaining to speed the time has come to
remove this burden that has impacted
weekday tourism in The Lakes Region
years ago I recall going to local
restaurants bars and other waterfront
properties and not being able to find a
DOT slip I would have to wait 20 30 40
minutes to be able to dock my boat
nowadays during the weekdays I'm not the
weekends are there's more boats than
ever on the lake there's more
registrations than ever but during the
weekdays I could drive from Meredith Bay
over to Alton Bay over to Wolfeboro and
um
so
in theory we are hurting our tourism
industry in The Lakes Region during the
week days
it's it's an issue I mean our weekend
numbers are up the voter registrations
are up but during the weekdays I've
never seen the lake so empty
please vote order pass or order pass
with Amendment to the broads only which
is the biggest widest open body of water
on Lake Winnipesaukee and in our state
other than obviously the ocean I'm
talking about Inland bodies of water
it is 30 square miles or about the size
of 14 Manchester airports and I think
everybody and everybody on this
committee for your attention
and considering misspelled thank you
thank you representative are there any
foreign
you said three minutes sir it would be
great
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the House Transportation committee my
name is representative John T McDonald
I'm from Cal District Six which
currently consists of the town of
Wolfgang
thank you for the opportunity to express
my opposition to house bill 1424.
before I start into the immediate of my
presentation I want to clarify a couple
of things that my previous colleague
uh stated there is a couple of other
speed limits on this in the state of New
Hampshire in particular I would say 271
colon 16 which is for Spofford Lake and
that's 40 miles per hour during the
daytime and 20 miles per hour at night
time
and also Squam Lake that speed limit is
made by regulation and that's 40 days at
and you could also look at some of the
lakes and ponds that have banned
horsepower restrictions on their body as
that in itself kind of being a speed
limit regulation
there are many different modes of
transportation and or recreational
vehicles operated within our state
they include automobiles motorcycles
snowmobiles ATVs and oh hivs
the state has historically adopted laws
and regulations to ensure the safe
operation of those vehicles
one of the most important laws is a
speed in which those Vehicles may be
safely operated on the highways and
trails
now let's consider all boats and
watercraft that operate on a several
hundred bodies freshwater lakes and
ponds our largest and most popular
league for boating Associates is of
course Lake Winnipesaukee
several years ago the New Hampshire
legislature after taking testimony
adopted a speed limit on Winnipesaukee
of 30 miles per hour from half hour
after Sunset to a half hour before
sunrise and 45 miles per hour at any
other time
HB 1424 would remove this important
comments and speed limit and we churned
us the problems that the original speed
limit law was created to address
an important difference between boats
and other models of transportation is
that a boat does not have brakes
if a boat operator must avoid a
collision the operator has no brakes to
slow or stop the boat
the options that the boat operator has
are to identify the penny collision and
formulate the necessary race of action
to take or at the best put the boat into
the take the boat out of forward here
but this action is not enough to stop
the ball from continuing in a forward
motion
a boat traveling at 45 miles per hour is
traveling at the rate of approximately
66 feet per second in perspective this
boat would travel the length of football
field in 4.54 seconds
as the speed increases to 65 miles per
hour the boat is traveling approximately
95.3 feet per second and would cover the
distance of a football field in
approximately 3.147 seconds
operating a boat at night also has a
challenges compared to daytime
operations
folks do not have headlights power boats
display a red light on the port side or
the left side of the boat and a green
light in the starboard or the right side
of the boat
those lights are required to be seen for
a distance of one mile
towards the student of the wheel of the
boat it requires 360 degree light light
and that must be visible existence of
two miles
on Lake Winnipesaukee there were no
street lights glowing business lights or
other source of Illumination commonly
found on our roads at night a photo
depends on the blinking white light of a
state Place navigation of Bowie or any
identified by light which is gained from
the shoreline or the islands and in some
cases the night the light from the Moon
in conclusion I hope that the committee
members will continue with our state's
efforts to providing a safe boating
experience for all the users of liquid
visaki and maintain the current speed
limit
representative Christy Barton
you said two to five minutes I hope
it's cut it down to like three possible
good afternoon Mr chair and house
Transportation committee
I am representative Christy Bartlett
representing Merrimack County District
19 East Concord
I'm here to testify against this bill
which would lift the daytime 45 mile an
hour speed limit on Lake Winnipesaukee
in my opinion this is madness
we have a boat and we have a seasonal
home in Alton we've had a boat on the
lake for the past 25 years and the
increase in the number of boats on the
lake has risen tremendously over this
time
I'm not just talking about small boats
either majority are power boats and they
are power more powerful and longer than
ever
most responsible Boat Owners recognize
the need for speed limits due to the
number of inexperienced boat operators
and the sheer number of boats
particularly on weekends
though there is a requirement for Boat
Owners to take a one-time safety course
and most do take that course there's
little to no enforcement
the few Marine Patrol officers are
spread very thin over New Hampshire
lakes and they have their hands full
with enforcement and emergency calls on
most days
add to this the many tourists we Welcome
to our state who rent a boat during the
vacation for just a few days
they are not required to take the safety
course but are issued a 14-day temporary
pass after reviewing the boat safety
manual
rental is a personal watercraft are also
very popular and these can hold up to
four passengers and can make very quick
turns
when there's an inexperienced operator
this can be a real hazard out on the
water remember that boats have no brakes
for those of you who do not own a boat 4
5 miles an hour is very fast trust me
we never operate our boat over 35 miles
an hour and that's plenty fast enough
the big cigarette boats can certainly be
operated much faster but with a very
long bow it's very difficult to see
ahead and there are no stop lights on
the water
how many voters know that the boat
coming from the right has the
right-of-way
I can't tell you how many times coming
the boat's coming from the left never
even slow down as they approach our boat
with the increase in tubers which have
as many as four on them often these are
children just dropping off one without
notice could lead to a tragedy
when a boater may not see someone in the
water while traveling at a high rate of
speed
when the speed limits were enacted a few
years ago the nighttime limit was a
compromise at 30 miles an hour
pitch black out on the lake at night
both of little red and green lights on
the bow and a white Stern Light that's
it no headlights personally we would
know never go faster than 15 miles an
hour at night
perspective is completely different at
night it's very difficult to determine
distance even of the shoreline
in closing I would argue that boats that
exceed 45 miles an hour belong on the
ocean and not on Lake Winnipesaukee We
Love Our Lake and want to continue to
enjoy it in relative safety and not fear
thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative any questions for the
representative
breaking my neck here seeing none thank
you
Rob Bob Flanders Flanders perhaps
Flannery oh yeah I see a little y there
you put down 15 minutes I hope that it's
good afternoon chairman and committee
members thank you for the opportunity to
come and speak to you today
um
as a preface to what I'm about to say
I'm I'm actually a waterfront property
owner on Alton Bay and so I I have a
good thing excuse me could you introduce
yourself did you we didn't hear your
name officially Bob Flannery
thank you who are you representing
myself and a group of other voters
you're welcome
our group represents over 500 people who
vote on Lake Winnipesaukee
that does not even include our many
friends and family who of course also
come along where we are responsible
or the constant people who constantly
complement our boats when parked at
restaurants and public docks
there was a tremendous outpouring of
support from so many people who don't
own a high performance boat but have
seen us at the Docks and out on the
water
for over a decade we felt as if the
speed limit has very much encroached
upon our right as safe responsible
boaters
and our freedoms as New Hampshire
citizens
this law never should have been passed
in the first place and we hope that
house bill 1424 can right the wrongs
that were made
as a community
safety on the water is Paramount concern
for us there's no group of people that
are more knowledgeable or exhaustively
thorough when it comes to Safety First
approach to boating than people who own
and operate performance boats
it is great concern to operate safely
and we as a community talk to each other
habitually about safe operations of our
boats
speed itself is not a safety concern
inexperience and intoxication are easily
the two factors that make boating unsafe
on the lake
a Marine Patrol supervisor has
corroborated this two years ago in an
interview with Laconia newspaper with
supporting statistics
there's been a lot of talk from the
opposition in regards to erosion to
Shoreline as a result of fast boats
giving off large wake
if any boat is traveling in excess of
about 40 miles an hour there's little to
no weight coming off of the boat
to say that fast boats would cause any
sort of increased erosion is absolutely
false
if it were true many of us would not be
driving these boats on the lake as
shoreline erosion is a major concern for
all of us who want property here or care
performance boats are constructed with
with as lightweight materials as
possible so they do not displace water
and as a result do not create a large
wake at any speed they are driven large
Leisure boats travel at medium speed 20
to 35 miles an hour that create these
damaging wakes
and the talk of stirring up sediment of
the bottom Lake as the boat drives over
it is also completely false aside from
shallow areas near shore where nobody
will be driving any sort of speed anyway
there are laws in place clearly
befriending this along with General
common sense
many people who oppose laws of publicly
stayed in various online forms their own
horror stories of out of control or
otherwise unsafe voters doing something
dangerous or concerning out on the water
very often these stories contain
something
about them going Full Throttle or going
too fast
we can say with great certainty that
these boats likely not even exceeding
the 45 mile an hour speed limit
am I getting close here can I just
summarize here quickly
summary the speed limit absolutely does
not affect Shoreline erosions on the
lake
the speed limit does not have any effect
in stirring up the bottom Lake
performance voters are generally the
safest most knowledgeable boat operators
Marine Patrol is state of that speed is
not a primary safety concern
inexperienced intoxication are
noise concerns are unfounded as the
noise regulations will stay the same of
Bill 1424 passes
Bill 1424 passing will have zero
consequences for paddlers out on the
lake
Winnipesaukee has a rich history of
performance voting and provides a very
safe and reasonable environment to
safely drive and increase speed usage
sir I think it's time okay
Okay so we've given you oh thank you
thank you for your for your
understanding thank you any questions
for
okay before we go on let me explain
a little bit about the construction
paper
the yellow construction paper when
representative Thompson puts it up means
you have about 30 seconds left
when he puts up the red one we ask you
to just
summarize and within 10-15 seconds and
get done with it I've got about another
I don't know
40 cards or so maybe 50. and I want
everybody to have a chance to be heard
which is why I'm doing what I'm doing so
if that offends someone then I apologize
but I apologize but I'm not sorry
because I want everybody to be hurt
Harry Vogel
now you said four minutes I would love
three minutes thank you and I do have
testimony
um
thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman and the
members of the committee for the record
my name is Harry Vogel I am the senior
biologist and executive director of The
Loon preservation committee I also sit
on the Environmental Policy Committee of
New Hampshire Audubon and I am
representing that organization as well
this afternoon
preservation Committee in New Hampshire
Audubon oppose House Bill 1424 for two
reasons the first reason is concerns
about our loon population
loons are a state-retten species in New
Hampshire lpc's intensive management has
more than tripled our population of
lands in New Hampshire since we began
our work in 1975 but our loans face some
big challenges including the challenge
of fast-moving boats and personal
watercraft
collisions with boats and personal
watercraft account for 13.8 percent of
known causes of adult living deaths on
Winnipesaukee that is eight times the
percentage of other lakes in the state
mortalities from boat collisions also
affect loon nesting success because once
you lose a member of a loon pair it can
be years before elune finds a new mate
and begins to be productive again
both collisions also affect the survival
of loon chicks young loons are small and
dark they are not easily seen by voters
and they're too buoyant to dive away
from a fast-moving boat
those fast-moving boats are very common
on Lake Winnipesaukee and loons on
Winnipesaukee have seen larger declines
in their population and breeding success
than in other areas of the state
balloon population on Winnipesaukee is
declined from an historical level of 40
or more pairs to an average of 28 pairs
over the past 10 years
collisions with boats and personal
watercraft are one of the largest known
causes of loon chick mortality on
Winnipesaukee
fewer than 7 out of 10 loons hatched on
Winnipesaukee survived to Fletch that's
10 below the Statewide average
loons on Winnipesaukee have fledged
fewer than 0.4 chicks per pair per year
and that is 19 below the Statewide
average
so Winnipesaukee holds 44 000 Acres of
water but last year it held just six
surviving Loom chicks that breeding
success is not enough to maintain a
viable population of loons on the lake
the second reason that Moon preservation
Committee in New Hampshire Audubon
opposed this bill is concerns about our
biologists and volunteers on the lake
this summer LPC will have 10 biologists
on New Hampshire's Lakes working for the
public good and to protect a socially
and economically important Wildlife
species
some of those biologists will be on Lake
Winnipesaukee and they will spend more
than 400 hours on the lake in a small
Boston Whaler our boats have a top speed
of about 35 miles an hour but they will
be able to cover the entire Lake very
well
over the years as we have seen more and
faster votes on Winnipesaukee I have had
increasing concerns about the safety of
our field biologists and our volunteers
on the lake
and speed limits have helped to
alleviate some of those concerns
and the last point that I would like to
make is that loons are the tip of the
iceberg the same issues that affect
loans affect mergansers and mallards and
otters and other wildlife
loons and our other Lake Wildlife bring
residents and visitors to our state they
contribute to our economy and to the
spirit that makes our Lakes special to
New Hampshire's residents and visitors
it would be a shame to lose the very
qualities that have attracted both loons
and people to our Lakes so the Loon
preservation committee and New Hampshire
Audubon support limiting excessive speed
on our lakes and so we oppose house bill
1424.
that is the end of my testimony I'd be
happy to take questions any questions
for the
Witness
my neck will be broken before the day's
next up is Bob
is total or stroller
you said 1pm I don't know what that
means
so it'll be three minutes right sir
hi my name is Bob strodel I am a long
time New Hampshire resident I'm also a
camp director and this will be my
49th year Camp I've seen a lot of
changes on the lake and when I first
heard that this bill was coming out for
consideration I thought somebody was
kidding me I just thought intuitively
that boats traveling around the lake at
45 miles an hour were going to be a lot
safer and are a lot safer than 65 miles
an hour
I love boats I've got nothing against
boats in fact probably everybody here in
the room I probably got more boats
registered in mining than everybody else
here we've got five power boats we've
got
another 15 sailboats that are over 12
feet long and we've probably got two
dozen smaller boats so I'm here just to
say to represent the kids that are
coming to New Hampshire there's 180
camps in the in New Hampshire my kids
I've got over a thousand kids that come
to Camp every year in Lakeland sake
please take a look at the first sheet on
this documentation here this shows you
where our camps are located Camp
brookwood's a camp Deer Run in Alton and
we also own Plum Island which by the way
is a loon Reserve too
we have been able we've had to stop some
of our things in the past for going
using Plum Island music kids out there
canoeing and you can see Robert's Cove
Marina on the right hand side the boats
get their gas out of rubber Scope Arena
Thunder about out into the bay there
into the broad area and so we have to be
very very careful when we use Palm
Island and that's just one example I'd
like to just copy give you of why we
want slower boats on the lake we love
boats we just want to slow our boats and
like to protect our kids and protect
people coming in from the outside of the
states thank you for listening and thank
you for the work you do for representing
all of us
thank you for your testimony any
questions
you've got five minutes on your card but
I hope you can cut it down to three
my name is Abigail Adams and I'm a
resident of Wolfeboro
and I voted in Lake Winnipesaukee for
about 40 years
I thank you for allowing me to speak
the U.S Coast Guard has released its
2020 recreational boating statistics
report revealing that there were 767
voting fatalities Nationwide in 2020 as
it's a 25 increase from 2019.
from 2019 to 2020 the number of the
total number of accidents increased 26
percent
there is evidence that the voting
activity has increased significantly
during the pandemic from reports of
increased boat sales insurance policies
insurance claims and calls for towing
and with increased exposure that is more
boating hours there were greater risks
of death injuries and accidents
interestingly this report lists the
primary contributing factors in
accidents in 2020 as operator in
attention inexperience
in proper Lookout and speed
alcohol use comes in sixth
the Marine Patrol has stated that
alcohol is a major issue in both
involving voter safety
this is at odds with the U.S Coast Guard
data and yes we know voting while
intoxicated has been a problem on
Winnipesaukee but a boat speeding along
at 65 miles an hour with an impaired
driver is far more likely to cause an
accident
than one that is obeying the speed limit
and clearly a family boater trying to
get out of the way and of what a
collision is going to have a better
chance of avoiding an accident if the
boat is traveling at 45 miles an hour or
less
the existing speed limit is working with
few speed related accidents since it was
put in to law
one accident does stand out and occurred
in 2015 when a swimmer accompanied by a
kayaker
on Winnipesaukee was hit by a boat going
65 miles an hour plus according to the
Marine Patrol report and boats traveling
at that speed simply do not have enough
time to see and react to other boaters
or swimmers and I've attached that
report for you
we need to keep in mind that the number
of people obtaining their boat license
in New Hampshire has increased from 6500
in 2019 to over 30
000 in 2020. this represents an almost
500 percent increase in new and
inexperienced Motors on our legs
increasing speeds even if Justin the
broads is unsafe
given the sharp increase in boat
registrations and the significant
understaffing of the New Hampshire
Department of Safety
and let's never forget that one of the
most high-profile fatal accidents
happened on the broads in 2008. when a
performance boat crashed into diamond
island
the broads is the Hub of the lake
and
people must pass from one port to
another Sailors Anglers and family
boaters use the broads
some family voters pull up anchor and
drift in the broads and where do you
define where the brides begin and end
are you going to put up a million
unsightly buoys to Define what deems
what you deem to be the periphery of the
broads and who pays for these buoys
finally I would just like to finish by
saying that I'm a member of the
Wolfeboro Waters committee and I work
closely with the latest Winnipesaukee
Association in New Hampshire lakes and
you should be aware that both of those
organizations oppose
bill number
1424 and we urge you to vote itl thank
you very much thank you any questions
next we have
three minutes is right on the money
I'm sorry the three minutes is right on
the money
then he had done that thank you I'm Rick
Flores I'm uh the happy husband of Mona
Perrault I'm on peralt sat in 418 the
last session so I wanted to ask you all
a favor and I appreciate and thank you
all the representatives here but I want
to do and again asking a favor of you is
pretty bold
please go home to your family and tell
them thank you because as a family
member supporting you I want you to
somebody testified today and wanted to
thank your families and loved ones and
that's me I wanted to uh come to you
today I'm actually in favor of the bill
one of the things I've been an
opportunity I currently own eight boats
uh the one that doesn't need any safety
certificate doesn't need any
registration is one that you paddle
that's the one that I have to actually
educate my guests who will be using that
boat wow we just had testimony now that
they have uh more safety certificates
being issued you want to jump up and
down and say thank you because that's
exactly the reason why we have a safe
voting in New Hampshire we have a 150
foot rule and I want to tell you now see
what that gentleman is standing he's a
sergeant and arms works for them that me
into all the way over here to this end
is not is actually less than 150 feet so
between that wall and that wall if you
come anywhere near another boat you have
to be at headways speed what happens is
when you're building in a large area of
water you're actually observing you have
who has the right of way and then you're
actually to reduce the speed that is the
reason that we have never had to have a
speed limit on the lake now we actually
had testimony of having a fatality on
the lake in 2008 that was not a speeding
boat
you understand that you're gonna you
have safety issues we have no more
or less safety issues and before we had
a speed limit what I'm sharing with you
is this that what we have is education
that is the reason in New Hampshire that
we have success we have success because
we implemented a safety certificate I
have mine right here okay and then I
share this with you
is that that I vote in other parts of
the country and I'm going to tell you
this at 25 miles an hour and a boat
coming within three feet of you or four
feet or five feet or ten feet is not
safe I bought a name I vote in New York
I vote in uh in Tennessee and quite
frankly what we have is something very
unique but what we have as an
opportunity as Representatives here is
to take a bill that was not necessary
you understand for 17 different times it
came to the transportation committee and
the transportation committee decided
they didn't need it okay what they did
was they gave it the house Recreation
and resource they did a bunch of studies
and that is the reason we have a speed
limit today because they didn't put it
to the professional people who
understand if you give a education Bill
to the fishing game the people who sit
on the fish and game will do the very
best that they can and I love them for
that because my wife did that when if
you don't have all the information you
get it but what happened was it was
passed in the committee that didn't have
it we do not need it and to this day
there's an opportunity to get a bill
that is not necessary it has never been
necessary
um thank you and I'll take any questions
you might have thank you any questions
you said five minutes ma'am I hope you
honorable chair and how's Transportation
committee members
according to the American Red Cross and
materials produced by the U.S Coast
Guard visibility is impaired by
reflections of light on water and a heat
wind wave action motor vibration and
noise creates a phenomenon called
boating fatigue boaters may be in less
than Peak physical condition
the longer a boat operators Excursion
the less alert he or she is most boat
operators spend less than 100 hours
annually operating their boat leaving
them Rusty at the throttle and the
former Marine Patrol director
stated that this number is actually 35
hours for New England voters people on
boats do not wear seat belts are not
usually fully contained in their boat or
wearing life jackets in other words
they're unprepared for the unexpected
according to the Canadian safe voting
data the effects of alcohol can be
tripled by voter fatigue
Coast Guard training materials show that
in a collision a 20 a 20 mile per hour
boat becomes airborne
and then as the speed doubles the force
of impact quadruples
enforcement authorities at lakes around
the country where there are speed limits
emphatically state that 95 to 98 percent
of Voters abide by limits just by having
them on the books and this is what we've
seen on the big lake over the past 13
years these enforcement authorities also
state that boating speed limits enable
them to enforce all voting laws more
effectively and that speed limit
regulation is critical to manage a
growing congested Waters and to maintain
the state's recreational values
as one enforcement person said speed is
an issue speed limits improve Reaction
Time cutting down on accidents and
injury boats have not changed in 40
years other than to increase power they
lack any safety equipment like cars seat
belts and airbags and for every fatality
there are 20 injury accidents and most
are head injuries which can result in
drowning speed and recklessness
recklessness are the most important
factors
most voters are unprepared for the
unexpected they are not experienced
enough on their boat and are
knowledgeable enough for the rules of
the road and not alert enough in the
best of times to the actions of others
the sun wind waves and weaving in and
out of heavy traffic of paddlers and
motorboats while watching for rocks and
buoys challenges the best of boat
operators
creating voter fatigue and easily poor
decisions
or decisions can quickly lead to
accidents
speed is a multiplier of these bad
decisions if we support the use of this
Lake for all Lake enthusiasts we must
maintain the 45-30 voting speed limits
law as it is without change because it
is working
slowing boats down and likely preventing
accidents
higher limits anywhere including the
broads would invite fast voters to
travel as fast as they want while taking
the right of safety and enjoyment from
the many others who Traverse the broads
The Hub of the lake needs to remain safe
as safe as any other part of the lake
under the 45-30 protective umbrella
last sentence what are the values at
play on this Crown Jewel of New
Hampshire
whose freedoms and safety are being
compromised if 60 70 and 100 miles per
hour is allowed in the same vicinity as
children and families
please vote itl on House Bill 1424.
thank you thank you ma'am any questions
next up would be
you said six minutes sir I would
thank you very much
I will try to chop my six minute
presentation down to three my name is Al
poznick I live in Alton Bay I've been
here since 1965 and during that period
there have been huge changes on the lake
and in my view this bill is all about
adapting to those changes
I'm here to represent the Lake
Winnipesaukee Sailing Association we are
a non-profit that was formed in 1988 to
teach sailing and promote boating safety
to youngsters and their families
we run one of the largest sailing
schools in the Northeast
over the course of a summer we put over
300 youngsters on the water
from ages 7 to 16 in small boats
we have a fleet of 35 sailboats and six
safety boats motor boats
of that Fleet the majority are under
nine feet long
this is the way to teach kids sailing
these boats are fragile and vulnerable
we we sail the younger kids in the
sheltered coves and the older kids Sail
on the broads in fact on a typical day
we may have four or five groups on the
water the more advanced kids in the open
Lake as I said
when conditions permit the younger kids
go out on the broads as well and
interestingly they're most likely to be
out there on the days that are most
conducive to high-speed motorboating
that is light winds and small waves
further once a week the whole school has
a full day outing and they sail across
the broads to ragged Islands
now I have been the organization's youth
sailing chairman for about 20 years
and hardly a day goes by that I don't
think about the risks of putting other
people's kids in the water in small
boats it's a scary proposition
45 miles an hour is plenty fast enough
there's been a lot of talk today about
restricting the speed limits or having
the speed limits unrestricted in the
broads
dangerous and really unenforceable as
somebody said the broads are Lake
Winnipesaukee is a hub
votes go at all speeds in all directions
while at the same time other people have
stopped to smell the roses to swim to
picnic or to sunbathe I shudder at the
thought of an ocean-going speedboat
charging through that scene at 80 to 100
miles an hour
thank you 45 miles an hour is plenty
fast enough
further on the broads
if you ask 10 experienced locals about
the boundaries of the broads you likely
get 10 answers maybe more and yesterday
I looked at a chart to see if I could
outline the area in question and I ended
up with more questions is the northern
boundary at Steamboat Island is it a
bear island is it a six mile island
does the broads extend inside of Welsh
island east of Five Mile Island thank
you and where does it end to the South
imagine a visitor launching a speedboat
for the weekend he won't have a clue
about the boundaries so uh in interest
of time I'll cut my remarks off here I
hope this committee considers not
passing House Bill 1424. thank you
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
I think you left your mask over there
sir
your mask is that yours on the table
thank you
three minutes if you cancer I appreciate
hi there everybody
um first of all thank you for your time
and I hope you're all doing well I'm
here to testify in opposition to HB 1424
because I know from personal experience
at the 45 30 mile an hour speed limit
works for the lake I feel safe in a
small silver and for a kayak or with my
whole family and our Runabout because I
know that if I follow the current laws
and in Vigilant I can avoid another
boater traveling at 45 miles per less or
less can you hear me all right by the
way in here okay
um so my topics my topics are speed
kills how we make the roads safe and how
that relates to the lake
I live on the broads and what I see and
finally the fast boats that are
available today the Insurance Institute
for Highway Safety said in 2019 that for
every five miles per hour you increase
speeds on a highway you increase
fatalities by 8.4 percent
it's common sense it's high speed you
have less time to react to prevent an
accident and the impact Force increases
with speed
accordingly the highest speed limit on
in New Hampshire is 70 miles per hour
not unlimited and that is only on the
most advanced Highway in the state these
roads are intentionally designed for
high-speed safety and to keep fast
moving cars away from roads with
pedestrians animals and slower cars we
put a lot of effort into making our
roads safe because it's part of a
trade-off between the number of deaths
that could occur with higher speeds
while allowing goods and people to move
at a rate that supports our economy
there's a trade-off that is a trade-off
we shouldn't have to make on the lake
when people are there to enjoy the water
and have fun
additionally piling a boat is nothing
like driving a car the wind engine noise
Sun waves and most of all all the other
boaters are factors that affect safe
voting the other people on the lake are
totally unpredictable as they have an
amazing time on the water they drive in
any direction they want they run at
different speeds they stop anywhere they
want none of these actions would be safe
on a highway
I live on the east side of Welch Island
looking over the broads toward
wolfborough so I know the broads are
full of people enjoying the lake their
numbers have been increasing because the
rest of the lake is getting more
congested and the broads are less busy
and beautiful place to be
another thing I see is that people don't
always obey the laws of the lake they
drive too close to other boats forget
that 150 foot thing they don't they
don't give way when the other person has
the right of way and they drive on the
wrong side of Bowie's to bark
navigational hazards
and then add unlimited speeds to this
behavior and you greatly increase risk
if the decisions made to increase the
speed limit thank you on the broads then
how would the department of safety make
it safe for other voters the broads
cannot easily be isolated from the rest
of the lake like our highways are from
the rest of our roads nor should they be
as that would make the largest part of
the lake unavailable for the majority of
boaters
finally last week I did some calling
around to boat manufacturers there are a
lot of very fast boats available there
are production boats that will easily do
100 miles per hour with some as fast as
175 miles per hour and you know people
will get them and want to run them we
have very fast cars on our roads too
some can go over 200 miles per hour but
they don't
speed limits keep us safe
thank you
thank you sir any questions
next up is
I told the other Witnesses I would
to the members of the House
Transportation committee my name is
Brian Hennessey you've already heard
many of the arguments regarding safety
and why HP 1424 is a danger to the
voters on Winnipesaukee I however want
to discuss two other reasons why this
bill should be voted Ito number one our
local economy prior to the passage of
the speed limit Winnipesaukee had
suffered from a reputation as being a
cowboy Wild West destination several
fatal and high profile accidents
involving high-powered speed boats had
contributed to this reputation and this
is why over 300 businesses signed in to
support the speed limit law we worked
very hard over 10 years ago to adopt
speed limits on the lake and can the
test that they have made a remarkable
difference on the improved atmosphere of
tranquility and safety for all who
recreate there
a recent study conducted by Dartmouth
College and commissioned by the Lake
Winnipesaukee Association showed the
lake generates over 17 billion dollars
for the region and the state Taurus
Anglers primary and secondary homeowners
are attracted to the lake for its
special peaceful Beauty and family fun
Recreation they feel safer boating as do
we with the current speed limits why if
all the speed limits for a select few at
the expense of men of the majority
here are a few of the businesses and
organizations that support us this time
around including six marinas and boat
dealers North Water Marine lanes and
Marina and Tuftonboro trexler's Marina
and moultonborough Meredith Marina phase
boat yard Guilford Dave's boat shop
Guilford
[Music]
um
we have a boating Club in Wolfeboro the
wcyc a poll of their members using
SurveyMonkey showed 95 percent of those
surveyed opposed the bill to eliminate
the speed limit 95 percent where in this
whole country can you get 95 percent of
the people to agree on anything
as far as organizations that are against
the bill Lakes Region conservation trust
Lake Winnipesaukee sailing associate
Association Sandy Island YMCA Camp
Christian camps and conferences
Camp kabian New Hampshire Camp Directors
Association Wolfeboro Waters the Lake
Winnipesaukee Association New Hampshire
Lakes Association loon preservation
committee New Hampshire Lakes management
advisory committee
number two that I wanted to discuss the
public supports our 45 30 speed limit on
May 5th 2010 the house voted 268 to 79
on a roll call vote in favor of the
45-30 bill on March 29 and 30 a Magellan
poll was completed showing 70 72 percent
those surveyed in favor of the 45-30 law
and 69 against 55 on the broads
uh and uh those signing in to support
the 45-30 law signed in on with a 10-1
majority
uh on May 18 2011 the full house voted
to uphold the 45-30 with 276 yeas and 75
Nays
45 45 not voting only three out of 20 or
15 reps from towns bordering the lake
voted against our 45-30 speed limit
imagine this imagine could you finish up
sir
no could you finish just okay all right
let's not fool ourselves HB 1424 is bad
for our local economy and having worked
in many tourist related businesses in
the state I can tell you that every
tourist dollar counts and if we're to
remain the Live Free or Die state with
low taxes we cannot afford to lose
Taurus dollars thank you thank you
I think so I think so
foreign
how are you I'm Gary Connolly a
waterfront owner of Alton I am a person
who was at all these meetings in the
beginning and very disappointingly this
was passed with very slow facts no one
has come up here today and told us how
many tickets are getting written per
year
the amount of money that is probably
spent through Marine Patrol and time
wasted chasing boats around is very very
concerning when there's a lot of other
things going on we're really not writing
the amount of tickets that we are out on
the highway not one person has come up
with facts you know the best thing we
have on our side we have had this built
for 14 years if you this excuse me if
this committee looks at the facts
nothing has changed zero there is no
it's not any safer all the accidents
they're talking about this is nothing of
New Hampshire they're talking about
stuff in the United States we're talking
about our Lake we have the facts and it
is very easy to see and I'm very curious
what kind of money is spent you know
through these Marine patrols to enforce
this and what kind of Revenue is coming
back we need this revenue for voting
education
um you know we're getting a ton of
influx of rental boats those
unfortunately are going to become the
more of the issue because the you know
it doesn't matter how fast you're going
if you're an experienced you're going to
hurt people and they don't get it and
there's 60 70 votes coming out of some
of these marinas and that's just one
Marina so where should we be spending
our money here it should be on education
and educating these people who are
getting out on the lake I mean I've been
on my the lake my entire life yes there
are a bunch of bad apples but there's
very few most of these hyper high
performance boat owners are spending
great amounts of money in our Lakes
Region and our economy and a lot of them
have gotten driven out because of the
speed limit and unfortunately the other
side they're not they don't register
their kayaks and paddle boats and stuff
like that they're not contributing
they're coming they're paddling they're
leaving I challenge how many people are
actually Waterfront owners here that are
actually you know really seeing this
Lake every day I mean it's there's a lot
of days on that Lake that it's a ghost
town there should be no reason that
there shouldn't be a Live Free or Die
and be able to get out there and enjoy
yourself and go faster than the posted
speed limit at this time
so thank you for your time
thank you sir any questions
seeing none
you
you've got the right amount of time on
this
good afternoon I'm Bob Conrad I'm a
resident of Wolfeboro and owner of North
Water Marine formerly thurston's in
Weirs Beach
while I became a marine owner in 2021
I've been a property owner on the lake
on Lake Winnipesaukee since 2000 and a
boater since
so I have experienced the lake with and
without speed limits and oppose HB 1424
as a boater I do not want to return to
the days of being intimidated and
endangered by high-speed boats anywhere
on the lake I personally had multiple
dangerous encounters with high-speed
boats failing to yield the right away
creating anxiety for everyone in my
party
as a marina owner on Lake Winnipesaukee
our business depends on families feeling
comfortable and safe boating on all
areas of the lake
families often multi-generational are
attracted to the lake which drives the
local economy through real estate and
businesses on and off the water removing
the lake speed limit or increasing it is
a serious risk to that attraction for
families in the local economy
people with fast cars are expected to
comply with speed limits on public roads
for the safety of all I think it's also
reasonable expectation that there are
speed limits on the lake for the safety
hole so as a resident voter and business
owner I oppose HB 1424 and ask that you
oppose it as well thank you
thank you sir any questions
representative tolarski thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question as a marine owner I felt you
might be a good person to ask this
question I'm specifically concerned
about the wording in this bill
where it starts with where no Hazard
exists not being a boater I I don't know
if if voters are aware of all the
hazards around them maybe you could
speak a little bit about that and the
other thing is the other question would
go for someone else so just that about
that where where no Hazard exists
so your question is I'm not sure I
understand your question okay the bill
itself says
where no Hazard exists that requires
lower speed for compliance
the speed will drop so it's basically
saying that the driver of the boat would
be aware oh excuse me where there could
be a hazard do you think that a
someone in control of a boat can be
fully aware of all hazards in the lake
particularly if they are an out of town
tourist who's never navigated in this
body of water well I I believe the
answer to that is no people do not are
not aware of all hazards on the lake and
as a marina owner we rent a small Fleet
of boats many of those come back damaged
simply because nobody knows where all
the hazards are on the lake and those
boats are not capable of actually going
okay anyone else
good afternoon
my name is Douglas Joseph I'm an
orthopedic surgeon in Nashua since 1980.
and a boater on the lake for 40 years
I'm adding my opposition
that helps build 1424.
my support is to keep the 45-30 law on
the lake as it is
with no changes
it makes no sense to change a law that
is working as it was intended
making the lake safer by slowing all
motorized boaters down
this includes keeping the 45-30 for the
broads
which composes a large portion of the
lake center
we vote regularly to the broads to go to
wolfborough Tuftonboro or to Center
Harbor for dinner shopping
and repair items as a physician involved
with trauma for the last 30 40 years I
can directly attest to the dangers of
high-speed injuries on our Lakes
highways injuries in boating accidents
are no different except that they may
also involve drowning
boat to boat crashes can be just as
devastating as with cars high-speed
voters cause injury and even death to
lower slower speed sailors kayakers
water skiers tubers and paddle boat and
swimmers
just like cars striking motorcyclists
bicyclists and pedestrians I have seen
these critical patients and treated
their grave injuries
I have counseled their grieving families
after these horrifying accidents
fortunately we have not seen these
high-speed accidents on Lake
Winnipesaukee for many years because of
the 25 45 30 law has been has been
working well since 2009.
the lake has been safer and more
pleasurable over the last 13 years
my family votes back and forth from
Ireland from our Island Camp to the
mainland
our trips have been much more
comfortable and less anxiety
than it was before the law each time we
cross the channel before these speed
limits we felt that we were voting for
our lives
I might add that they ignore the 150
rule
to the channel
and
vote wherever they want to voting was
not fun in those days it was terribly
stressful
please do not take us back to those
times
vote against HB 1424 and keep 45 30 as
it is with no changes
please keep us safe
thank you
thank you sir any questions
okay I apologize ahead of time for the
next name
Barbara
Avanti how close am I
it works
ladies and gentlemen of the
transportation committee my name is
Barbara fioravanti I thank you for this
opportunity to address you with my
concerns about safe voting on Lake
Winnipesaukee specifically with regard
to speed limits I have been enjoying
this beautiful Lake in Summers for some
65 years and am now a proud year-round
Lakefront resident of tufton borough
I enjoy many types of water activities
swimming kayaking sailing and
motorboating
and I also fly an amphibious aircraft
I feel we all need to figure out ways to
enjoy the lake without spoiling it for
others
Winnipesaukee is a large lake attractive
to many types of boaters from campers
and kayaks
through families and pontoon boats and
sailboats to operators of powerful
high-speed Cruisers
the popularity of all types of boating
on Winnipesaukee has increased
exponentially as the density of boats
traveling at different speeds increases
so does the potential for conflict
the 45 mile per hour a day 30 mile per
hour Night speed limit was instituted to
reduce the potential for deadly conflict
and boat density has only increased
since its Inception
HB 1424 is a proposal to eliminate the
speed limit especially on the central
part of the lake known as the broads so
that high-speed boats could take
advantage of their capabilities of 60
plus miles per hour
with that level of boat density that now
exists that would mean that sailboats
pontoon boats and other small craft but
not safely operate in the broads or even
across from one side of the lake to the
other
defining the length of the broads is a
straight line from Robert's Cove to
Birch Island it's about 10 miles long
at 60 miles per hour the trip would take
10 minutes at 45 miles per hour it would
take just just over 13 minutes
I don't think anyone considers time
saving as the motivation for traveling
faster than 45 miles per hour in a boat
on a lake it is of course the thrill of
flying over the water as fast as you can
go maybe seeing if you're the fastest
boat on the lake
the speed limit makes the dangerous
practice of racing less appealing as
anyone traveling over 40 mile 45 miles
per hour is subject to a stop by Marine
Patrol with a possible ticket and
further investigation of the condition
of the boat and the operator
I strongly urge the committee to reject
HB 1424 in the interest of safety for
all those who enjoy Lake Winnipesaukee
thank you for listening thank you ma'am
any questions
Mr Downey Mr Downey
yeah my name is John hello
Mr Downey if you have written testimony
could you maybe just summarize what
you're going to have in yourself
quick move things along even better
appreciate that yep thank you
so my name is Sean Downey from Merrimack
New Hampshire I've been uh boating for
30 years I am one of those so-called uh
high performance experts I'd say as I
got 15 years experience with those boats
a lot of the statements that have made
about them are incorrect
okay uh you know the land of a football
field to stop at 45 is absolutely
ridiculous
uh
you know I just to educate some of you
that might not be
Otis or even know Lake Winnipesaukee
it's huge
the broads itself from Guilford to Cow
Island about three miles
from Welch Island to Wolfeboro
six miles
that's 18 square miles of space
that's tremendous
and at any given day on in the summer
again I've been bowling there for a long
time
there might be 10 bolts in the broads in
18 square miles
and just to prove that to you you can
Google Lake Winnipesaukee and pull up
the lake
on the satellite and count the boats on
a summer's day
you'll see that the sand bars are loaded
with boats
so it's going to give you an accurate
description that it is a very busy day
and you can count them that also goes
for Welch Island all the way to Santa
Harbor which is eight miles
that's a huge body of water that lots of
people can have fun on
but yet everybody wants to complain that
it's dangerous in the broads a lot of
people barely go near the branch they're
in all the Bays if you look again at
that Google Map you'll see that Meredith
Bay is busy you'll see that pogus bay is
busy you'll see that there's a lot of
traffic going into Alden
those are the busy areas
but the broads are wide open there's
plenty of space there for all of us
not to mention I know there's a lot of
kayakers and paddle boarders and you
know small fishing boats is 800 plus
lakes and ponds in New Hampshire
why is it that Lake Winnipesaukee the
only big body of water in New Hampshire
has to be a victim
to to uh the performance Focus that want
to go out and enjoy the lake too
we spend a lot of money on these boats
we should be able to have fun when it's
safe
you know I understand some people get
scared but there's a 150 foot rule in
place
to guarantee that we're not near them
and trust me when I say when we're going
65 70 miles an hour we don't want
anything to do with being near them
nothing
because they're unpredictable too
especially the rent is
These Guys these people are coming up on
the weekends renting boats with no
experience zero
they take a short course they give them
the keys to the boat and they say have a
great day they don't know the lake they
don't own the laws they don't know the
buoys
they don't pay attention when they turn
those are the people that are the
problem not us
I hope you guys can see that
that lake is gigantic sir
thank you any questions I appreciate it
Kathy Boselli
one to two minutes that'd be great
the very best
just uh my name is Kathy vaselli I'm a
resident of Guilford New Hampshire I
live on an island six months of the year
and I've been there for 40 years like
many others I've seen huge changes on
the lake and I have three things I want
to say quickly try to define the broads
and everyone will come up with a
different opinion so if you're trying to
use that body of water and Define it and
enforce it
it's it's going to be very very
challenging yes this is 150 feet I see
violations of it of that as a safety
zone every single time I go out of my
boat I'm trying to teach my
grandchildren safe boating and we're the
ones who have to make accommodations for
those who are not following that rule
um I cannot take my grandchildren into
the broads which is right next to where
I live to go water ski or tubing on
weekends because there are not 10 boats
there's way more than 10 boats we have
to avoid that area for safety reasons
I'm also here to speak on the behalf of
Genie Forester who is a state senator
who uh former state senator who was not
able to be here today so this next
section is a letter from Jeannie good
afternoon thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for allowing my
testimony to be read into the record 11
years ago on April 19 2011 I testified
against SB 27 a bill to remove the speed
limits on Lake winnsasaki just like
today's hb1424 back then I spoke on
behalf of constituents from my district
I had received hundreds of emails
letters and phone calls nearly three to
one those Communications were in
opposition to removing speed limits the
communications came from residents
voters Camp directors Marine owners
business owners and members of the
hospitality industry the overwhelming
message was keep the current speed
limits in place and the legislature
listened since the speed limit has been
in place people feel safer and use and
enjoy the lake more Lake Winnipesaukee
is user friendly and accommodates
everyone from kayakers and swimmers to
fishermen and boaters during testimony
in 2011 I always I also spoke from a
personal experience as a boat owner and
passenger over 40 years ago on the Labor
Day weekend I almost lost my mom and
Young Brother in a boating accident
including my father we were all
passengers on a boat that hit a
Breakwater at top speed the owner and
experienced voter and close friend of
the family lost control and as a
consequence my mom ended up in a coma
when she was tossed from the back of the
boat and hit her head on the galley door
my brother lost his spleen when he was
thrown through the window my dad and I
both suffered broken ribs and
miscellaneous injuries I'm sure our
family friend believed he was operating
The Vessel at a safe speed that was
reasonable and prudent but his judgment
was wrong and the injury suffered by my
family had real negative and permanent
results I urge the members of the
committee to vote against hp1424 because
the current limits are working thank you
Genie Forester thank you could we have
that for yes for Clark
three minutes please my name is John
Spooner good afternoon Mr chairman and
committee
um
my grandfather bought diamond island in
1931.
and he had had a high performance Chris
Craft that went 64 miles an hour
and he'd given that boat up when he was
uh 67 years old because he thought his
reaction time had dulled down but I was
conceived I was an ice out baby I've
spent I'm 54 years old and I've been
boating for 49 years I got a boat when I
was five years old
currently I have four high performance
boats
and
um
I feel as though the speed limit should
be pulled in the broads it comes down to
more about boater etiquette and
education
and I don't believe that a kayaker
should be in the broads to be honest
with you that's just common sense it'd
be it's a little bit different these
days there are more and more boats
but
it seems as though it's the other people
who do not know the rules on this Lake
and I see it every day and they can be
going 25 miles an hour
and they're throwing out a bigger wake
they're within 150 feet
so all I'm saying is that I think they
need more more education
about safety
and speed
I don't see it as an issue in the bronze
thank you
thank you any questions
Diana McNabb
foreign
if you have written testimony you could
probably just summarize and that would
be great okay yeah thank you thank you
so much I'm Diana McNabb and in the
summer I live on Welch Island
and that overlooks the broads and so far
we've heard so many good reasons to
oppose this bill
um what I was what I picture when I look
out over the broads
in the summer is like an old-fashioned
neighborhood where you see the big trees
and the kids playing and the
skateboarding and the biking and the
people coming and going but the lake
version of it there's the water skiers
and the families boating there's the um
two the kids tubing behind boats and
falling off
there is all the kids jumping off the
boats and swimming
there's the sailboat lessons and the
small boats with the grandkids learning
how to boat on the water with the small
horsepower motors and of course this
the kayakers and paddle boarders and the
kite borders and all these guys fall in
the water and you can't see them
so in the neighborhood there's speed
limit on land and some
on the water I think there should be a
speed limit to prevent the high-speed
vehicles from barreling through the
neighborhood
I think the existing speed limit has
worked well so I ask you to please
oppose
this HB 1424 and keep the speed limit
thank you thank you can we have that for
written test for the clerk
um or no I can I emailed it okay thank
Mr chair if you have written testimony
could you like somebody I set my
testimony in I have a few copies here
and so could you summarize what you had
think you try to hit a few points really
quickly uh my name is Weldon Bosworth
I'm from Guilford I'm a part owner of
Island property in Winnipesaukee uh
before I retired as a marine biologist I
spent many years on the ocean and lakes
responsible for the safety
of both boats and Personnel so I think I
speak from a perspective of experience
as well as training there's a few things
I want to emphasize uh number one we
talked about causes of accidents and
where they all felt in the priority of
causes in the Coast Guard statistics
these are not independent they actually
can work together so I'd just like to
point out if you get in an accident for
lack of attention and you're going fast
the results are a lot worse number two
the force of an impact
basically increases by
a quadruple a doubling of a speed so
anytime there's an impact with either
another person a place or a thing it's
four times as much force the other thing
I'd like to put is a lot of people have
said the increased use of the lake
I'm a statistician as well I think we
turn in terms speak in terms of
probability that the more boats on the
lake the higher the probability that
sometimes somewhere people are going to
get in trouble and this is particularly
true as we've heard with a lot of
inexperienced voters I think in the last
10 years the number of people running
pontoon boats and don't know a darn
thing about rules of the road has
tripled
it isn't always clear sailing and flat
water out there so I'm not concerned
about people and it's flat calm it's
when we have uh high winds and waves
uh that's when the probability increases
having speed zone speed zones has been
suggested here on the broads should work
both ways if we're going to control the
board and the broads with a higher speed
I can tell I can tell you about a number
of places on the lake that should have
significantly lower speed limits think
about that
it isn't just accidents
that speed limits control or decrease
it's about near misses it changes the
experience on the lake from one of
somewhat of enjoyment they're looking
behind your back like we all do on 93
when Speeders go by
lastly getting right to the end here I
just turned 80 so I'm going to
philosophize a little bit I don't know
if anybody's heard about the tragedy of
the commons
tragedy of Commons talks about the use
of a common resource where each
individual has their priorities unless
it's regulated in some way that Commons
the worth
of that Commons degrades so I think
that's what we're doing here a good
decision was made 13 years ago
I don't think we need to change it for
the benefit of a few who could travel
east another hour and go as fast as they
sir you said eight minutes but uh please
thank you
my name is Richard Smith
I am here representing the New Hampshire
Bass Federation
and uh
I was born and raised in South Dakota so
that explains why I talk funny
but we're mainly into fishing we turn
the clock back
12 13 years ago when this issue was
it wasn't aimed at us
we basically want to fish
and we don't want to spend a lot of time
getting from point A to B to C to D
so
while it wasn't intended to restrict us
it was really aimed at the the big high
performance bolts like the formulas the
donzies the cigarettes the mountains
but it did have a negative impact on us
and uh give you a little
insights into what this bass fishing
stuff is all about
the vaults we run are performance bolts
they're fishing machines they're built
for big water
these are some of the safest voters
that you're ever going to find
when they're up on speed up on pad as
they say they make very little wake so
that's a big positive
most of the bass fishing tournaments you
hear about are small clubs
so when they have a club tournament on
Winnipesaukee
there's only like six seven boats that's
it 7 A.M how many boats you think around
water
almost none
and these bass boats are designed to
cover a lot of water typical bass
fishermen will travel
over 50 miles
during the day
the whole ideas minimize the amount of
time spent traveling Max whoops maximize
the amount of time fishing that's what
they're all about
a lot of people have talked about safety
issues
I'm hoping Mr chairman
that you will call on before forward
through today uh Captain Don Levy
because he will tell you the objective
facts
I know going back to 2007
uh
rain Patrol did a
study
on speed they use two different kinds of
is during the summer nine different
areas
and it was
three thousand eight hundred and fifty
three bolts
that were clocked
do you know how many of them went over
45 miles an hour
not many
it's fair pack the top speed that they
recorded
was 62 miles an hour that was by three
boats three boats
New Hampshire has always been a safe
voting State going back then and to this
day but I'd like you to ask Captain
Dunleavy to verify that
and uh
so the other points I was going to make
is around the handout so that's going to
save a little time so thank you very
much
quick question please
representative Hill who I can't see
right now thank you Mr chairman um my
question is uh then go back to your
phone to the microphone please
okay thank you
um my question is whether the number of
uh bass tournaments has decreased since
my general impression this is a voting
itself has grown especially over the
last few years
uh
there's been a significant increase in
fishing and uh
but I would say that the the bass
fishing Community is remained pretty
stable
was that what your question was yes
thank you very much
and I'll be happy to answer any other
questions except I think you reveal my
best fishing spot thank you with any
other questions thank you
okay
I think it's Warren Hutchins but I'm not
sure
Hutchins is the last name anyway
yeah yes it is
good afternoon I'm Warren Hutchins a
multi-generational New Hampshire native
and I live full-time in Guilford New
Hampshire I've been an active boater on
Lake Winnipesaukee since
1979. my family has grown up on the lake
like you I've devoted my time and
efforts for the people of New Hampshire
I served the 34 communities of the Lakes
Region Planning Commission for over a
dozen years on its executive committee
multiple years as elected chair in this
capacity I was very involved with the
10-year Transportation plan process
it is as you know a ground-up planning
process originating with the communities
in the state it is primarily focused on
Transportation safety then comes
capacity then comes economics
Transportation safety was grounded into
me as I commanded a line hall trucking
company in combat in Vietnam
over a dozen years ago the lrpc
supported speed limits on Lake
Winnipesaukee with testimony before the
House and Senate committees
the Laconia city council also supported
voting speed limits in order to promote
safety and economic development
there are very few regulations
concerning voting operations on our
lakes in comparison with other modes of
transportation
you know the many regulations on our
roads to promote to promote safety for
vehicles and people
the Lakes region is a driver for our
state's economy in large part due to
Lake Winnipesaukee
please vote itl on this very selfish
request of a few for their personal
pleasure at the expense of the general
voting voting public
the current War 4530 was a negotiated
law and at that time there was much
discussion concerning the bra
excuse me the brides this is a major
part of the lake and is like a major
intersection that so many different
sized boats need to cross to get to
Major ports or residential areas on the
lake or for simple enjoyment
please honor the work of your
predecessors in the House and Senate and
do not modify this simple regulation
it is very hard to determine the
accidents that have been prevented by
the sensible regulation defining speeds
as we do on our roads please let your
common sense and experience Prevail
thank you very much
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
I'm going to take a stab at this one too
Jen
stop
ski
hi good afternoon I'm here today my name
is Jennifer dropsky representing my
company Seven Lakes Marine Service as
well as myself I'm very much in favor of
removing the speed limit on Lake
Winnipesaukee the greatest issue on any
lake is the new boat owner driver and or
the driver being intoxicated
these are the two greatest factors on
any Lake for having the risk of greatest
injury I know that because we see this
damage firsthand
as for the speed boats Making Waves the
wake of a big Cruiser or wakeboard boat
is three to five times greater than that
of the boats of other boats on the lake
it's simple physics that the faster a
boat with a plating hull goes the less
wake it will make
these boats are equipped with safety
equipment
with the alarm placed to wear a safety
lanyard and many of these boats being
outfitted with a foot throttle which is
just like taking your foot off the gas
the boats will stop if the driver is
ejected the drivers of these boats are
experienced drivers as well many of the
owners that own boats go in excess of 45
miles an hour have a vast boating
experience and knowledge on how to
operate and handle them very very well
some of the owners race some of the
owners raise boats professionally my
husband as well did who won a couple of
World Championships in an outer limits
race boat neither he or any of his peers
have been in any type of recreational
boating is the incident caused by speed
the people that are running these boats
love and take great pride in what they
own they congregate in groups much much
the same as people in muscle cars do on
a cruise night they want to go home to
their families at night too so Contra
contrary to what we've heard these guys
have families too
they would never jeopardize that they
just want to go out and do what they
love
please review the speed limit on Lake
Winnipesaukee it does not make sense for
any of the arguments that I have seen
today and let's restore Live Free or Die
can we have that did you already hand in
some written testimony no yep never mind
okay
next up is Nancy Watson
said four minutes I would enjoy for
three minutes
especially if you have written testimony
then you can just summarize what you
good afternoon thank you for your time
today my name is Nancy Watson and I'm
from Eaton I've been boating on Lake
Winnipesaukee for 40 years my husband
and I own our home on Rattlesnake Island
located on the broads for 35 years we've
had to travel through the broads to get
to our home
I oppose abolishing the daytime boat
speed limit and any amendments that
would designate the broads as a speed
limit exempt area
limit in effect for the last 13 years
works
my home is situated on a cent of 60
steps up from the dock this affords me a
very elevated view of the broads on busy
days especially weekends and holidays
there's a huge volume of traffic
traveling up and down the lake and
crisscrossing this area before the boat
speed limit I witnessed boats traveling
at high speeds in One Direction often
impacts even a half a dozen weaving
around slower traffic
just like clockwork about 10 minutes
later these same boats often returned
heading in the opposite direction in the
same manner
observing the action of even one
high-speed boat among those traveling
slower evokes disruption anxiety and
fear since the boat speed limit has been
in effect these worries have been
greatly reduced I see more fishing boats
trolling more kayaks more paddle
boarders venturing further out in the
broads and more boaters swimming off
their boats and drifting on a beautiful
day
for an evening to watch the sunset
and you've all heard already since
what's happened since covet hit
people are seeking new forms of
recreation and many of them are new and
inexperienced boaters voter education
does not equate to experience its
practice practice
when I pull into the marina from where I
Boke the parking lot is full this was
once reserved for weekends and holidays
but now it's all week long it's mostly
from start to the end of the season and
I've been at this Marina for 24 years
more people are using the lake which
translates into more boats if you've
ever driven a boat especially on a busy
day you understand you need to stay
focused on the boats that are heading
towards you the ones to the right the
ones to the left the ones behind you
they're coming from all different
directions and they're all traveling at
different speeds I can't tell you how
many times I've looked in back of me
only a moment later there's nobody there
and then somebody passes me from behind
and that 150 foot rule I mean uh good
luck it's really hard to do that when
you you're it's a busy weekend and
there's a lot of boats that are out
there buzzing around from every
direction
um it's a good idea it's a good concept
you know it means it means it's business
but there are rules and that there's not
one person in this room who hasn't
experience being cut off or I'm forced
to divert around another boat that's
passing on the incorrect side we've all
been there
there's no Lanes on the lake and there's
no breaks on a boat
the enactment of the speed limit has
provided everybody time to slow down
which that has probably saved a personal
property or maybe even a life
if the broads is designated the no speed
limit Zone where will the boundary
markers be placed and who's going to
maintain them you know they do move
around due to the weather do you expect
Marine Patrol to do this and to also
monitor the boundary mean Patrol
frequents the broads much less than
before their personnel is stretched
pretty thin right now and humans are
humans we all make mistakes the faster
you go the faster you've got to think
I've seen more than my share of bizarre
unfortunate happenings on the broad
including a drowning ejected and pinned
passengers from an out of controlled
airboat and an overloaded sunken boat in
its recovery I've assisted the victim of
a plane crash there's a lot of crazy
things that happen on the broads and
increasing the risk of more mishaps by
adding speed limit to the equation is
not a wise choice doing where the speed
lets at this time when the lake
especially the broads experience an
increase in traffic is not a common
sense good judgment decision I asked the
committee to itl HB 1424 so all can
equally enjoy Lake Winnipesaukee and
feel safe thank you thank you any
questions
I'm assuming Mr Watson that you have
pretty much the same testimony as your
wife so you could perhaps summarize what
both of you have
I understand that but it interests at
times
uh yes my name is Mark Watson and I'm
from the same house as my wife in Eaton
and I'm here to oppose HB 1424 being on
Rattlesnake Island for the past 35 years
with an unobstructed view of the broads
I've written firsthand boat traffic
before and after the speed limits before
the speed limits I witness on many
occasions one-on-one racing not to
mention four five across boat racing
since the implementation of the speed
limit that soda racing has vanished
thankfully the second pattern I see
uh both pre and post
speed limits is
the boater that goes up and down the
lake repeatedly over and over again
it takes my calculations 10 minutes 40
seconds to do the entire length of the
broads from north to south that means in
one hour I can make six trips
how much faster do I need to go and
where else can I go
the lake isn't large enough to
accommodate unrestricted speeds without
endangering or intimidating other
boaters and swimmers that is why the
speed limit law was put in fact in the
first place
I crossed the broads quite often from my
Mainland dock in woofboro to my
Rattlesnake Island home I have an
observed at either a single lit or unlit
buoy the delineating where the broads
begin or ends
because of the broad's hub-like
geography traveling from any of
wolfeboro's five major Bays requires
a large amount creates a large amount of
crisscoffing traffic by increasing
speeds in the broads you require boaters
to make quicker decision on who has the
right-of-way and the safest way to
proceed all boaters in one vicinity
process what is happening and what may
happen next having a single boat
traveling at a much higher speed
intensifies the action and reaction
others must make make
Philly currently has a speed limit in
place that maintains an equal and safe
blame people of
a playing field please don't destroy
something that works
why would anybody want to do it with the
speed limits the only answer can be they
want to go faster
since uh there really isn't any place to
go except up and down the broads the
next question becomes how fast can I go
and is my boat faster than yours
unfortunately I believe this will bring
us back to free speed limit racing
foreign
racing I saw Surfers
windsurfers kayakers and other small
craft having to make way
for boats bearing down out of them at
high speeds
paddle boarders and jet skis have become
much more commonplace on the broad since
speed limits were imposed at times the
broad can become quite busy with smaller
watercraft his Insanity to consider
increasing boat speeds in summary speed
limits have helped improve the Lake's
boating experience for many there are
now more boaters than ever bringing in
larger economic gains for central New
Hampshire
slow down high-end performance vote on
lake misaki has been a wonderful thing
for traditional recreational activities
and marine life
speed kills keep a law that is working
for the people in New Hampshire in place
please vote itl HB 1424
thank you Mr Watson any questions
good afternoon how you doing I'm here
for the bill
um yeah this lake has a lot of Powerball
history it has the first ever sanctioned
speed race held on a body of water in
the United States we've had wooden boats
in the 1930s taking people for rides at
60 and 70 miles an hour much more than
today's speed limit where boats are
45 we need to compromise here the lake
is big enough for everybody and I feel
like at least today we should find a
compromiser eventually you know we share
the same speed limit as a snowmobile on
a trail that is six feet wide the same
exact speed of 45.
boats are much more safer in a much wide
open space
it's again the lakes for everybody to
enjoy and I feel like we're we're a very
small percent of people out there
enjoying boats that might go faster than
that
um you know you plug one of these boats
in a computer because everything today
is computerized at higher throttle
levels
out of 300 hours on a boat you have six
percent at Full Throttle
if this speed limit changes we're not
out there all day doing this but you
know our Lake can roll with five six
foot waves bigger boats can get places
when nobody else is out there much safer
and you do have to go at 45 55 65 to get
up on top of the waves to be safer
moving
um
so again just some of those facts I've
been doing this uh our families about
Lake since 1972. I've been boating all
43 years of my life I representing a lot
of working people that can't be here
today friends family people retired in
Florida and uh there's much more of us
that couldn't be here saying the same
thing as me thank you
thank you sir any questions
is
Mary strobber
marks right
show us how well I print
don't need either good afternoon my name
is Mark Straubel and I serve as the
associate executive director for the
YMCA Greater Boston overnight camps and
we operate three camps on Lake
Winnipesaukee Northwoods Pleasant Valley
and our Sandy Island Family Camp our
Sandy Island Family Camp is a 66 acre
Island adjacent to the broads and we
have children and families of all ages
to participate on a daily basis out in a
lot of watercraft all around the island
and we've been operating that camp for
over 100 years and we have seen all
kinds of challenges with boating
um and we are not
um in favor of this bill we believe that
the current 45 mile an hour and 30 mile
an hour is common sense and appropriate
to have those limitations and I will
yield the rest of my time
next up is Jeff
I like the three-minute rule
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
in opposition to House Bill 1424 is
written my name is Jeff Keeler I'm a
lifelong resident of Epsom New Hampshire
and has spent portions of the summer at
Lake Winnipesaukee for the last 66 years
I'm currently a property owner in Bear
Island and have witnessed the tremendous
growth of activity on the lake that has
come with the inevitable development of
it my family and I enjoy fishing
canoeing kayaking and sailing on the
lake but have found that Crossing from
East bear Island to five and six miles
Islands in these slower moving vessels
has become unsafe at times other than
Daybreak when boat activity is at the
lowest level and point yes I do own
power votes and pay registration fees as
well
we recognize that we have little
maneuverability in these small
slow-moving vessels and we have right
life jackets and use brightly colored
paddles to provide the greatest
visibility to oncoming vessels despite
our precautions these activities have
resulted in some very close calls when
inattentive drivers driving at high
speeds have come very close to hitting
us
I lost one neighbor several years ago to
a boat accident in Meredith Bay when a
high-powered boat accelerating to get on
plane ran their boat over from behind
killing him instantly and injuring his
wife and children another Island
neighbor son was newly killed at about
the same time when a boat traveling at
high rated speed on a rainy day drove
through the side of their boat causing
Serious injury to both of the occupants
there's a reason that we have speed
limits on our highways it is simply
unsafe to allow Vehicles capable of
traveling at excessive speeds to do so
the same holds true for travel on the
big lake boats unlike cars are not
traveling in designated lanes and as
such the safety approach voters is
subject to constant scrutiny of others
in the area to provide for reasonable
options in avoiding collisions
clearly if we to provide opportunity for
everyone to use this state resource
safely and enjoyably it is imperative
that we control speeds to avoid
unnecessary injuries and deaths I just
make one final Point people are talking
about the need to get from point A to
point B if you do the math to go from
Center Harbor to Alton Bay which is
approximately 26 miles at the current
speed limit of 45 you make it in 35
minutes that's fast enough
thank you
thank you sir any questions for Witness
they can understand
next up is Michael Dempsey
okay
thank you chairman thank you committee
I'm here in support of lifting the speed
limit
hb1424 I own a
high-speed powerboat
and uh
I'm all about
a common sense solution to this
I understand there's been problems in
the past with a lot of people
you know bring up a lot of other things
the 150 foot rule and
accidents that happen because of alcohol
or driving at night
um
this is about
everyone enjoying the lake
I love looking at loons I love the
wildlife
you know I'll get out on a kayak once in
a while I'm not a big fan but you know
we can all
enjoy the lake in our own way
um I think the Marine Patrol could
look at people on the broads and saying
you know you're operating unsafe even if
it wasn't a speed limit if it's a clear
day and you're not within
any boat within sight
I don't see why you can't go over 45
miles an hour
um
I don't go too fast too often because
every time I do I break something so you
know I I just think if I'm out in the
middle of the broads
I can pull anchor and or not even just
float around and look around there isn't
a boat for like miles
and
you know it's it's about a daytime
compromise and I'm all about the
nighttime speed limit because
you can't see at night and that that's
common sense
you know we have sound ordinances which
quieted the boats down and I get that
that's common sense I respect that but
if there could be a common sense
compromise that's all we're asking today
and uh I appreciate you hearing us and
like a lot of these guys said
this is part of the lake I I moved here
from Mass in 86 and I remember coming to
the Weirs and looking at all the big
votes going oh you know that's so cool
you know and that's what Winnipesaukee
used to be and I understand sometimes
you know
I don't know where I'm going with that
but that those days are never coming
back and I'm fine with that but a
compromise where we could all get along
is all we ask
thank you
no questions
good afternoon my name is Stephen
Spalding I live in the Hollis and
moultonborough
I oppose this bill for reasons of safety
I oppose it also for the following
reasons
more speed
means more fossil fuel consumption
which means more pollution and more
climate change
more pollution more noise and less
wildlife
means a diminished natural treasure
let us protect and Preserve
that with which we are blessed
thank you
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Jake Paul
okay we got through Richard Spaldings
this one is from Newcastle oh wait
I'm I'm Richard I don't you must have
already
somebody else came up before earlier
didn't you come up earlier Richard
Spaulding Newcastle that's you that's I
yes and Richard's falling from where I'm
Richard Poulet b-o-u no you're you're uh
okay thank you I thought we had two
Richard spauldings here okay go ahead
sir
thank you very much I'm Richard
Spaulding from Newcastle and
moultonborough
and I just wanted to address the 150
foot rule which I think is a key factor
in some of the presentations here
it's been in effect for a long time I
don't know how long
it's a very sensible regulation
um and it clearly
is established to call for no high speed
within 150 feet of a raft of the shore
of another boat whether it's a kayak or
a yacht
and
it is observed most of the time
but I can tell you from first-hand
experience in a kayak in this on a stunt
fish
in this gift on a Wrath
frequently it is not observed
and when another boat comes at 30 or 40
miles an hour close to you
if you're about to tack in a sailboat or
whatever it is not a comfortable or safe
situation
to have those occasional times when it's
not observed
meaning a boat could be coming 45
over 45 who knows how fast is just going
to make that risk
that much greater and entirely go
counter to the purpose of the 150 foot
group
that's all I wanted to emphasize because
I think it's a critical factor in
what's going on on the lake
thanks a lot
thank you sir
any questions
now
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Dick boulay and
I represent the firm of Denny and bullet
this afternoon I did not plan to testify
but I'm very concerned that the prime
sponsor by the way I'm opposed to the
bill the pine supports in the beginning
of the hearing said that he had an
amendment
where is the amendment we've been
talking about the bronze I mean is there
another is there an amendment before us
I didn't see any Amendment okay I just
want to be sure that there was there
wasn't an amendment but we have not
talked about the definition of the
bronze
what is the bronze exactly I think I
know but do we all know what it is how
do we measure it how do we enforce it
how much is it going to cost
to do that if you're going to put buoys
up too so people know they're in the
bronze I think there's too many
unanswered questions just on that alone
I think the bill should be defeated
it'll be glad to answer any questions
thank you thank you
as anyone
does anyone else wish to speak who has
not had the chance to speak on this
subject
you you've already you you you've
I'll bring this up in a moment thank you
all right sir good afternoon Mr chairman
my name is Tim Dunleavy and I'm captain
for the division of State Police
overseeing the Marine Patrol unit the
department of safety does not take a
position on this bill but I am available
for uh as a resource if any of you might
thank you any questions
representative Sykes
Captain thank you for taking my question
certainly
are there any
um
specific
correlations between in studying speed
and accidents available for New
no sir there are not we have not done
any uh examination of any data as it
relates to speed in accidents in New
Hampshire
representative tolarski
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Captain can you
please describe I know from what I
understand the testimony some of these
power boats can go 100 miles an hour
the reaction time of a driver trying to
stop a boat
and how much distance it can travel
before it actually can come to a safe
stop
I will do my best to answer your
question it's very difficult question
because there are so many factors
involved the first factor that comes to
mind for me is the operator is reaction
time the reaction time in the marine
environment can be impacted by so many
different variables it can be it can be
affected by their attention
it can be affected by just their
physiology and whether it be age or or
mental capacity to to observe
issues that would cause them to react
those things can be impaired by being
out in the weather all day long
vibration heat humidity alcohol
distractions on their boat the grandkids
tugging on their shirt to go tubing all
these things can can impact their they
are known as stressors in the marine
environment that can impact a person's
reaction time
uh once a boat that is at speed uh wants
to stop there are a variety of ways to
make that happen certainly you can just
chop the throttle as they would say
bring the boat right back to neutral and
there is going to be a time lapse before
that boat comes to a complete stop there
are evasive actions with a steering
wheel in the throttle at the same time
and a person can even go into reverse
but none of those are as effective as
the brakes in an automobile might be as
we've all come to experience as motor
vehicle operators there is a delay in
time before the vessel will come to a
complete stop and depending upon the
vessel and its original speed those
times and distances will vary
you all set yeah okay representative
Sykes
captain again thank you for taking my
question
um we heard some testimony earlier that
the in New Hampshire there's a
significant increase in the numbers of
um votes being registered is that a true
statement
I'm sorry sorry I didn't hear the
question well I we heard earlier that
there was a testimony that there's been
a significant increase in the numbers of
boats that are registered here in New
Hampshire recently is that a true
statement that is a very true statement
sir we the last two years uh the covet
pandemic and outdoor activities in
general certainly has been a significant
factor in the increase in voting in New
Hampshire and across the country and
we've seen a jump uh the last two years
and about 10 000 registered votes on our
water we're around 107 000 Last Summer
on Pace again for that number this year
one of the studies that I've seen
indicates that a really important
correlation between boating accidents
is density of use
would there not be a correlation between
the numbers of voting licenses that have
given out and the densities that we'll
see on the lakes and Waters of New
Hampshire
certainly New Hampshire numbers show
that the more registered votes we have
the higher accidents a number of
reportable accidents we have a year
it's important to look closely at that
type of of accident data historically
the number one cause of accidents in New
Hampshire are probably
striking our natural hazards rocks ledge
outcroppings we are the granite state
and sometimes that Granite shows itself
and sometimes it's just under the
surface the second leading cause for
accidents frankly is Damage Done to
other boats while boats are trying to
dock in Close Quarter maneuvering and
Then followed by personal injuries
good afternoon Captain thank you for
your testimony certainly sir
um
we here in the house and in the Senate
and with the governor we pass laws when
we pass a law we intend for it to be
enforced yes sir and the bottom line is
do you have the personnel and the
resources you need to enforce this law
if we allow this to be
repealed
and allow these boats to go apparently
as fast as they want because we've had
no other proposed speed limit as part of
the bill
how would you enforce that
well certainly we have geared up to
enforce what's on the books now we have
the equipment we have the speed
measuring devices
so if this bill were to pass and that
speed limit were to be repealed it's not
going to change our officers day-to-day
activity our speed enforcement now is
part of their routine Patrol it would be
one thing that we just are not paying
attention to frankly because we wouldn't
have a law on the books to enforce
do you anticipate that would result in
increased accidents
it's difficult to say our numbers before
the speed limit and sense the speed
limit are showing a trend of the same uh
pretty much the same data Trends
accident related certainly because we
have a law on the books now we do have
numbers of speeding tickets and warnings
that that are being issued by officers I
don't have those numbers off the top of
my head I can tell you that there are
more issued at night after the half hour
after Sunset because more boats frankly
can exceed that speed but we do have
some Daytime violations as well
thank you very much certainly
representative Stevens did you have a
question
as I know wrong
I'm sorry representative Rambo go ahead
thank you and thank you for taking my
question Captain
um as it's come up in discussion a few
times I'm hoping in your role if you
could Define for us what the broads are
I will agree with many of the speakers
that have come before me and that a
definition of the broads is going to
depend on the person you're speaking
with
um it was summarized by by one lady
earlier where depending upon what island
what point
whether you go all the way to Center
Harbor in you know Six Mile Island
inside outside of Welch Island do you
include the 40s there are so many
variables
um and it would be very difficult in my
opinion absent uh significant signage
and um promotion of those boundaries for
even the visiting public to be aware of
that zone
not impossible but it would be a
challenge
Crawford
thank you Mr chairman do do you we have
um
fines for speeding on the lake are there
are there like when you go 20 miles over
the speed limit in a car
there's a fine for that do we have fines
like that for boating we have there is a
fine but it is set by the court it is
not one of those fines that has a flat
rate
like you might find on the road
depending upon how much over the speed
limit you're going there are numerous
violations in our state where it's up to
the court or the judge to decide once
there's a conviction in place and this
is one of them
spot thank you and if we eliminate the
speed limits on Winnipesaukee and you
have your radar or whatever you're using
out there
with a boat going 100 miles an hour
there's no recourse for that I'm
assuming it would definitely changes I'm
sorry it would that not be a violation
we would still have uh based on this
bill's language we would still have the
nighttime speed limit to be enforcing
and so that equipment would still be
used for that purpose but during the day
there would not be a need to stop
somebody doing 100 miles an hour unless
we're unless we're seeing other outside
factors involved maybe close proximity
to another vessel
congested traffic in one of the little
towns around the lake where a speed like
that would rise to the level of being a
careless and negligent operation of a
representative Walsh yes thank you sir
thanks for coming to a couple questions
if you don't mind Mr chair you seem
pretty knowledgeable on the increase of
voter registrations can you go a little
further how many more rentals per se do
you know the number of increase in
rentals or maybe by a percentage
I do not have a number on the renters I
can tell you that
um the number that you heard earlier for
the number of people who became
certified to operate a boat in New
Hampshire last year topped over thirty
thousand we have not seen a number like
that in 20 years when the law first came
into effect on average we're between six
and eight thousand a year and we were
over thirty thousand um
during the peak coveted time part of
that I will say was a result of the
governor's emergency rule where the
proctored exam requirement was waived
it's not really a follow-up just another
question in your experience because I
know you've been doing this for a long
time in all reality what's your
estimation how many boats can actually
it's really a difficult question
um
I I wouldn't dare I wouldn't dare guess
that there were again so many factors I
would say that the
average boat on Winnipesaukee that
you're seeing now is probably 24 foot in
length and up
there are kayaks and sailboats and so
forth that I wouldn't count to that but
registered votes you're probably looking
at an average of 24 and up
uh certainly low we know in Industry
that
um right now to get a an engine between
two and 300 horsepower you're waiting a
year to get it so the demand is on those
higher horsepower vessels
um
depending upon the whole configuration
how many people are in it whether they
could do 45 or 55 is really going to
vary
a lot of them sir I would say are on
and if I can I just I get in late and I
apologize and he did I hear that the
department is not taking a position on
representative field
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
I spent time on on Winnipesaukee and and
then the broads and I do know that
weather can come into
on the lake in a in a hurry
and I also know that I've run into a
number of floating objects out uh in the
broads in various times so what I'm I'm
trying to ask is in relation to those
two items
how would
um
how would the braking distance of of
boats
be affected by by those two items when
we're when you're increasing that speed
from the current set speed up to an
unlimited number it's it's the braking
distance that I'm mostly worried about
when you see a floating log or something
like that
so in a condition as you've described
with high winds and high wave action
certainly that's when we do see our
hazards and those hazards can be logs it
can be things that have washed off the
beach in the form of kayaks and canoes
it can be boats that have broken their
Mooring chain and are unattended
um certainly
with the rough water comes the ability
for a boat to travel high speeds to be
reduced most of the boats you're going
to find absent your out show offshore
power boats and your real big
vessels that are made for that type of
weather are going to have to be at
probably a slower speed than 45 to just
be able to operate in rough choppy
weather but your higher speeds of boats
that are capable of exceeding those
larger speeds are also capable of being
operated in a heavier chop so depending
upon the height of the chop the type of
wind and storm you're dealing with
may become an issue for Speed and
braking distance or it may not sorry for
the non-answer but those are the factors
involved no I guess I guess I follow up
quickly
um sure thank you what what I'm getting
to is is enforcement
um and and items of that nature
how would you determine when it is
unsafe for uh going at a at a higher
rate of speed I guess
is that we would certainly look at the
the boat's ability to navigate those
types of waters
if if occupants are being tossed around
if the if the boat itself has limited
free board or or free space before it's
taking on water whether it's an enclosed
bow or a bow Rider that is open to the
elements those are all things that we
would look at the general safety of that
vessel operating in that weather and if
the officer determines that that the
operator by their actions is endangering
themselves of somebody on that vessel we
would stop them
yes sir
representative Gorski
thank you Mr chairman I thank you
Captain for taking my question we've
heard many testimony today about
inexperienced boaters can you give us a
sense of do you have any like numbers or
statistics of citations you've given to
inexperienced voters while they're on
the lake
we do issue and as time has gone on and
and more and more people uh visiting our
state come from a state that requires it
those numbers have started to drop a
little bit off the top of my head I
don't know our enforcement numbers for
the education requirement I would be
happy to get those for you and pass them
along to user certainly
we started off when we first introduced
our own new folks first required voting
education in this state which was a
early 2000s we were the ninth state in
the country to require it now there are
only three that don't require it or some
form of it but offer it so we're finding
a lot of people visiting us already have
um Captain
how big is this tool that we're going to
take away from you if we were to accept
this bill
how big is the weather how big is this
tool the speed tool that we're going to
take away from you
um I I would defer to the public sir the
department of safety historically has
taken the position on these types of
bills to allow the boning public to
decide how they want to be regulated and
I think that's a fair description of
where Department of Safety stands on on
this by removing this as a tool
um
but
although
um
I'm not sure that was the answer I was
looking for but
um
is this
is this going to be I mean it's it's
like we took the speed limit off the
highway
how big a safety
tool is that for you to have speed
limits on the highway
and I can't imagine it's any different
I don't want to put you on the spot
remember I think you are putting him on
the spot because I don't think it's he
can't determine that yeah it would I
guess it would all depend on
um
how people would react to the ability to
travel at those High rates of speeds and
where they would choose to do it
um and and all of those would be factors
I'm sorry representative tolerski
thank you thank you for one last
question I appreciate it
um
I imagine that there's not many bodies
of water
with the
sheer area of Winnipesaukee that allow
these types of boats in the region
is there a chance that if we repealed
the speed limit
normally we think that drawing in
tourism is a great idea that this could
have an unintended consequence
of a huge spike in the number of these
high-powered boats coming to
Winnipesaukee which would then
exacerbate any safety problem we could
not knowing how many would come
um
I'm not sure certainly I guess that
possibility exists while at the same
time it you know it it may not increase
our numbers it all depends on how many
were to come how fast they would choose
to go
it's it's again a lot of variables and I
apologize for the non-inser I just don't
know how we could predict in other words
you can't predict the future
it's it's it's it's different there's
just so many factors correct okay so
oh go ahead
thank you and this is an easy one I know
you're not taking a position on the bill
as as a division do you have any
information in terms of data since the
the uh speed limit was put in place and
I forget what year it is offhand
we're just I'm seeking information that
may help the committee come to a
decision on this is there anything you
can provide as a division or Department
the the only data that we have available
and and we've provided it to many people
in this room today is our accident
numbers because pre speed limit law we
had accident numbers post we had
accident numbers we didn't have speed
numbers Before the bill came into being
because there was no need for it so the
the the common denominator here would be
accident numbers uh and we have provided
those to to many folks in this room
today and I think you've heard some
testimony to that
um the the number of accidents directly
related to speed
um
again you need to look at the finer
details of the accident itself was
speed a factor or a contributing factor
can all depend is it boat to boat is it
boat to shore is it boat hitting a rock
in which case any speed could be
considered a factor
so we we by our data set and what we
have to report to the Coast Guard
annually is just was speed to continue
contributing factor
someone doing 15 miles an hour around a
public dock is too fast and so speed was
then a consider a contributing factor so
those numbers you need to look at each
report individually to see how fast the
boat was going did it hit a rocket did
it hit another boat or hit an island and
so there are many variables but
typically we do not have more than five
or six boat accidents a year where speed
was a contributing factor whether that
thank you Mr Dunleavy don't forget to
fill out that pin card it's awesome
seeing that
they have no no more pink cards so
standard
together